Call a doctor and tell him I'm down Call a doctor and tell him I'm down Well, so let's get into it. I am here with Himes Weitz, which... Am I pronouncing it right? Is that right? That's right. Himes, actually.
给医生打电话，告诉他我状态不好。给医生打电话，告诉他我状态不好。好吧，那我们开始吧。我和海姆斯·韦茨（Himes Weitz）在一起，那个……我发音对吗？是这样吗？没错，其实是海姆斯（Himes）。
Yeah. I'm here with James Waits, who's a social worker, and now he's going to start part-time at Taproot. We're going to get into his specialty. Yeah, I don't know. What is it? Have you ever seen the Oliver Stone, like Alexander, where
是的。我和詹姆斯·韦茨（James Waits）在一起，他是一位社会工作者，现在他要开始在Taproot兼职了。我们要深入探讨他的专业领域。是的，我不知道。那是什么？你看过奥利弗·斯通（Oliver Stone）的电影吗，比如《亚历山大大帝》，里面
the accents are just like the actors are just going crazy? Angelina Jolie was weirdly miscast as a Macedonian, like her choice for ancient Macedonian, which is just pretty similar to Greek. It's not that. It's just to roll every letter.
演员们的口音简直疯了？安吉丽娜·朱莉（Angelina Jolie）饰演马其顿人选角非常奇怪，她对古马其顿语的选择，其实和希腊语很像。不是那个问题。只是她把每个字母都卷舌了。
So the whole movie, she's just in the beginning, and then there's like flashbacks to her or whatever. But just every scene with her and Alexander is her just being like, never will there be an Alexander likeander like you alexander the great wow oh she's all her r's yeah i oliver stone i wonder um i wonder how he's doing yeah i heard out i heard his jfk movie turned out to be turned out to be true did you do you hear that is that right no i don't know i'm just i'm just teasing let's make it a joke i uh when we have like the a lot of the like a lot of the bigger guests uh i feel like there's kind of like an arc in the middle where everyone's kind of uncomfortable oh yeah if i ever get like a college professor or something i'll just do like
所以整部电影，她只在开头出现，然后就是关于她的闪回之类的。但她和亚历山大在一起的每一场戏，她都在说，永远不会有像你这样的亚历山大，亚历山大大帝，哇，哦，她把所有的r都卷起来了。是的，奥利弗·斯通，我不知道他现在怎么样了。是的，我听说他的《刺杀肯尼迪》（JFK）电影后来被证明是真的，你听说了吗？是这样吗？不，我不知道，我只是在开玩笑。让我们把它当个笑话吧。呃，当我们有很多大牌嘉宾时，我觉得中间会有一个弧线，每个人都有点不自在。哦，是的，如果我请到大学教授之类的，我会做一个
a cold open or something where they're just laughing before i hit record so they're like oh so they're just coming in like all right like and it just looks a little more natural yeah uh like with james mappy or somebody like right before i hit it like yeah i mean you wrote all this stuff about the aspects but like how do you know that were you there i mean he's making that up wait are you saying i'm not a big speaker yeah they're like what i'm a big guest so uh we're talking about doctors, MD burnout and health care. I mean, so James's specialty is going to be taking care of. And this is your specialty is interesting to me for a lot of reasons that don't get talked about in social work school. But like he wants to talk about the way he wants to treat like when MD and correct me where I'm wrong here, like MD fatigue,
冷开场，或者在录音前让他们先笑一笑，这样他们进来时就会觉得，好吧，这样看起来更自然一点。是的，就像詹姆斯·马皮（James Mappy）或者其他人，就在我按下录音键之前，就像，是的，我的意思是，你写了所有关于这些方面的东西，但你怎么知道的？你在现场吗？我的意思是，他在编造。等等，你是说我不是个大牌嘉宾吗？是的，他们会说，什么？我是个大牌嘉宾。所以，我们正在谈论医生、医学博士（MD）倦怠和医疗保健。我的意思是，詹姆斯的专长将是照顾他们。你的这个专长在很多方面让我很感兴趣，这些在社会工作学校里是不会被谈论的。但他想谈论他想要治疗的方式，当医学博士——如果我说错了请纠正我——比如医学博士的疲劳，
you know, the stress of preparing for medical school residency and those big complex systems. And also, you know, a lot of your skills apply to academia, high performance executives, you know, people that are operating in a sector where a whole lot of balls are bumping up against each other. There's a whole lot of things that they have to be aware of all the time and then just the long-term kind of fatigue and strain that that does um especially when those systems change or are in the middle of changing like like maybe health care is i don't know if um you got a couple jumping off points there is there anything i'll just hand it over to you what do you what do you how do you uh how do you describe what you do yeah no uh that's perfect.
你知道，准备医学院住院医师实习和那些庞大复杂系统的压力。而且，你知道，你的很多技能也适用于学术界、高绩效主管，你知道，那些在很多事情相互碰撞的行业中运作的人。他们必须时刻意识到很多事情，然后就是长期的疲劳和压力，尤其是当这些系统发生变化或处于变化之中时，比如医疗保健，我不知道，如果你有几个切入点，有什么我可以……我直接交给你，你如何描述你的工作？是的，不，那太完美了。
Yeah, all that plus just any type of just health care worker and mental health kind of aspect. We don't talk about that in social work school as much. I kind of want to tell a brief story about how I got into it. Basically, back in 2019, I i went to a i went to a training it was a compassion fatigue training out in the red barn in leeds which is awesome it's equine therapy it works with kids a lot but they're partnering with jc duggard i thought equine therapy worked with horses well i'm sorry you're gonna you're gonna have to roll with it oh Oh, damn. You derailed me. Go ahead. Already. So, yeah, J.C. Duggard.
是的，所有这些，加上任何类型的医疗保健工作者和心理健康方面。我们在社会工作学校里谈论得没那么多。我想简短地讲一个我如何进入这个领域的故事。基本上，回到2019年，我去参加了一个培训，那是利兹（Leeds）红谷仓（Red Barn）的同情心疲劳培训，非常棒，那是马术治疗，对孩子很有效，但他们正在与杰西·杜加德（J.C. Dugard）合作。我以为马术治疗是和马一起工作。好吧，抱歉，你得顺着这个说下去。哦，该死。你让我脱轨了。继续吧。已经开始了。所以，是的，杰西·杜加德。
I don't know if you're familiar with that. You probably know more about that than I do, which she was kidnapped as a kid in like 1991. But during like my first year in college, she was rescued. I mean, that's 18 years later. I'm pretty sure. Yeah. 2009. So anyway, so she's rescued and, you know, she got rehabilitated and back into everything. I mean, she had two kids and she got reunified with those
我不知道你是否熟悉。你可能比我更了解，她小时候在1991年左右被绑架了。但在我上大学的第一年，她被救了。我的意思是，那是18年后。我很确定。是的，2009年。所以，总之，她被救了，你知道，她接受了康复治疗，回到了正常生活中。我的意思是，她有两个孩子，随着时间的推移，她与那些
kids over time. I mean, there was a lot of trauma, obviously that had to be worked out there, but now she turned to kind of like, um, basically her foundation has a lot of aspects of like reunification with families and children and parents and that type of trauma. This training was here. She came to Alabama. We were working on compassion fatigue specifically with law enforcement. Mainly because I remember she telling us that the biggest issue coming back once you got rescued is how many people were like not on the original case anymore um they just kind of it burnt it burned them out i mean it's
孩子团聚了。我的意思是，显然有很多创伤需要解决，但现在她转向了，基本上她的基金会有很多关于家庭、儿童和父母团聚以及这类创伤的方面。这次培训就在这里。她来到了阿拉巴马州。我们专门研究针对执法部门的同情心疲劳。主要是因为我记得她告诉我们，获救后最大的问题是，有多少人已经不在原来的案件上了，他们只是……这让他们精疲力竭，我的意思是，这
like searching for you know 18 years you can't imagine one cop sitting on a case for 18 years and how much like how that works in movies, you know, and true detective or something, the guy is just skinnier and smoking more cigarettes and his wife's left him. And then, you know, year 20, he solves the case.
就像寻找了18年，你无法想象一个警察在一个案件上坐了18年，这在电影里是怎么运作的，你知道，在《真探》（True Detective）或者其他什么电影里，那个人只是变得更瘦，抽更多的烟，妻子也离开了他。然后，你知道，第20年，他破案了。
But I mean, realistically, I mean, these people can't, can't do that, you know? Yeah. I mean,
但我的意思是，现实中，这些人做不到，你知道吗？是的，我的意思是，
they, they get, they burn out to get. And so, and then, but that creates, so not only is that initial burnout pretty bad, but it creates this thing, you know, compassion fatigue where they just don't want to do anything else.
他们会精疲力竭。所以，这不仅导致了最初的倦怠，而且还造成了这种情况，你知道，同情心疲劳，他们只是不想做任何其他事情。
I mean, they just go, you know, status quo, mediocre, like I just want easy cases or I want out of law enforcement kind of thing. We weren't there specifically because I had compassion fatigue at the time, but we were learning kind of just the ins and outs of how to be more aware of it. Um, and so that compassion fatigue got me thinking a lot of like, holy crap. Um, I'd spent a lot of years in community mental health and I can see where this applies, um, across the board. So, um, and then obviously transitioning over to, you know, big, you know, hospital work and things like that. You see that all the time of the system that we're kind of set up in kind of like ruins us. I mean, it ruins kind of like, I think it takes away, it takes away your passion um and you know i i unfortunately i witness med students who are not even in residency just feel so bummed about the world because of what you know it's already set
我的意思是，他们只是，你知道，维持现状，平庸，就像我只想要简单的案件，或者我想离开执法部门之类的。我们当时去那里并不是因为我有同情心疲劳，而是我们在学习如何更敏锐地意识到这一点。所以，那种同情心疲劳让我思考了很多，天哪。我已经在社区心理健康领域工作了很多年，我可以看到这在各个方面都适用。所以，显然过渡到，你知道，大型医院工作之类的。你总是看到我们所处的系统在某种程度上毁了我们。我的意思是，它毁了，我认为它夺走了你的热情，而且，你知道，不幸的是，我目睹了甚至还没进入住院医师实习的医学生，因为他们所知道的，已经为他们设定好了，就对世界感到如此沮丧。
up for them yeah yeah that is i'm glad you're getting into everywhere that i what i see on my end you know because you're you've been in a hospital you know like you know been in therapy but i mean that that does seem to be the thing and like i'm not a conspiracy theorist and then i think there's like a guy in a back room smoking the cigar moving the chess pieces but i do think a lot of things that are bad about the systems that we inhabit they continue to get worse are sort of allowed and enabled because they're useful for the system having more control and more money and whatever and just so many changes with health care like um the amount of paperwork that doctors have had to do.
是的，是的，我很高兴你深入探讨了我所看到的一切，因为你曾在医院工作，你知道，也做过治疗，但那确实似乎是症结所在。我不是阴谋论者，我不认为有一个人在密室里抽着雪茄移动棋子，但我确实认为我们所处的系统中很多糟糕的事情，它们继续恶化，在某种程度上是被允许和助长的，因为它们对系统拥有更多控制权、更多金钱等等是有用的。医疗保健方面有太多的变化，比如医生必须做的文书工作量。
There were some, I was like listening to some clip yesterday. Somebody was saying it's gone up over like 350 times or percent, you know, percent, 350% more paperwork that you're expected to do around all these sectors, especially insurance. And I think he was in family, just family practice. But I believe that because it's like we would we have all of this insurance stuff on our end where claims aren't paying and we're having to go and the insurance we're having to call and see what's
昨天我听了一些片段。有人说它增加了超过350倍或百分比，你知道，百分比，你需要在所有这些部门周围做的文书工作增加了350%，尤其是保险。我想他是在家庭医学领域。但我相信这一点，因为就像我们在我们这边有所有这些保险的东西，索赔没有支付，我们不得不去，我们不得不打电话给保险公司看看是怎么回事，
up and the insurance company's like well they haven't seen a primary care doctor this year we don't know what their cholesterol is and it's like well why do you need a referral from a primary care doctor if you were sexually assaulted and and this person's in therapy, and there's a time limited thing. And, you know, but it's just another hurdle that they can throw up, like the health screen or whatever, that the more people who don't do it, the more money that they make, and now healthcare is getting pinched, insurance is getting pinched, there's not as much room for middlemen. And they their answers to throw it to doctors. But I think a lot of people get angry with their doctor, because that's what we hear from patients as people are like angry why would i have to see my doctor it's like your doctor had nothing to do with this you know unless they work you know
保险公司说，好吧，他们今年没看过初级保健医生，我们不知道他们的胆固醇是多少。就像，好吧，如果你遭受了性侵犯，为什么你需要初级保健医生的转诊？而且这个人正在接受治疗，而且有时间限制。而且，你知道，但这只是他们可以抛出的另一个障碍，比如健康检查之类的，不去做的人越多，他们赚的钱就越多。现在医疗保健受到挤压，保险受到挤压，中间人的空间不多了。他们的回答是把问题推给医生。但我认为很多人对他们的医生感到愤怒，因为这是我们从病人那里听到的，人们会愤怒，为什么我必须看我的医生？就像你的医生与此无关，除非他们工作，你知道
and you see like they're not but people are pissed basically they have to go which i think when people that you're interacting with are hostile or think you're part of the problem even if that's erroneous that also does some some psychic damage there you know you want to use dnd language yeah no uh and and it sucks um it mainly because the fact that you know they're learning this system um that they don't know how to get out of it and there's really no way out of it um and i i sit on a teaching team team at the hospital and I kind of give basically a talk every week about, you know, you have to push through in this aspect. Like this is something you can't control and kind of get them back to where they do have control, which is taking care of patients better and having these things. And they actually learn through that of like how their interactions with these patients and when these patients get better, that brings them back to a good spot. But then, you know, at the end of the day, it's just like, crap, you know, there's nothing left for this.
你看到他们不是，但人们基本上很生气，他们必须去，我认为当你与之互动的人是敌对的，或者认为你是问题的一部分时，即使这是错误的，那也会造成一些心理伤害，你知道，你想用龙与地下城（D&D）的语言吗？是的，不，这很糟糕，主要是因为他们正在学习这个系统，他们不知道如何摆脱它，而且真的没有办法摆脱它。我坐在医院的教学团队里，我基本上每周都会做一次演讲，关于，你知道，你必须在这个方面坚持下去。这就像是你无法控制的事情，让他们回到他们确实有控制权的地方，那就是更好地照顾病人，拥有这些东西。他们实际上通过这些学习到，他们与这些病人的互动，当这些病人好转时，这会把他们带回一个好的状态。但后来，你知道，在一天结束时，就像，该死，你知道，没有剩下什么了。
We can't offer anything more. We can't do this. Like, what was the, you know, what was the point of today if tomorrow is just going to suck. Well, and I think that what the amount of bureaucracy and BS and that you used to be allowed to get away with was self-limited for MDs by the fact that they could just leave. They were usually people who were bright and upwardly mobile, and if not, had the capacity to be and could say, okay, I'm going to go do something else. But what we've done now is we've saddled that process to so much money that there's no one who has it lying around even if you are incredibly wealthy. So you're under all this debt that you've already taken out.
我们不能提供更多东西。我们做不到。就像，今天有什么意义，如果明天只会更糟。嗯，我认为官僚主义和废话的数量，以及过去医学博士可以通过直接离开来逃避的程度，是因为他们通常是聪明且积极向上的人，如果不是，也有能力成为那样的人，并且可以说，好吧，我要去做别的事情。但我们现在所做的是，我们把这个过程背负了太多的金钱，以至于即使你非常有钱，也没有人有闲钱。所以你背负着你已经承担的所有债务。
And now that filter of how much basically you can abuse, the system can abuse these candidates, is that filter is removed because I just borrowed $300,000. And unless I finish this thing, then I have no hope of ever being able to pay that back. And that seems like a scary development to me in the way that those systems are run. Yeah, they're locked into it pretty much. I mean, I just had a conversation with one med student the other day
现在，系统基本上可以虐待这些候选人的过滤器被移除了，因为我刚刚借了30万美元。除非我完成这件事，否则我永远没有希望还清那笔钱。这对我来说是一个可怕的发展，关于这些系统的运行方式。是的，他们基本上被锁在里面了。我的意思是，我前几天刚和一位医学生谈过，
and they're just thinking like, after I go through med school, I don't even know if I want to enter residency. And I'm like, why? You know, I mean, how are you going to make back? You know? Yeah. Yeah, you know if i want to enter residency i'm like why you know i mean how are you gonna make back you know yeah yeah you know you gotta do something i mean you can go i don't know what they could do after that i mean they become md after but no i i had to sit down with them i was like no you just pick something find a passion if it's not this or that you know uh then make back your money or you're gonna always gonna be sitting in this place where um yeah that debt is wild um yeah but what i'm seeing is it's it and even with
他们只是在想，在我读完医学院后，我甚至不知道我是否想进入住院医师实习。我说，为什么？你知道，我的意思是，你打算怎么赚回来？你知道吗？是的，是的，你知道如果我想进入住院医师实习，我说为什么，你知道，我的意思是，你打算怎么赚回来，你知道，是的，是的，你知道你必须做点什么，我的意思是，你可以去，我不知道他们在那之后能做什么，我的意思是，他们之后成为了医学博士，但不，我不得不坐下来和他们谈，我说不，你只是选择一些东西，找到一种热情，如果不是这个或那个，你知道，然后赚回你的钱，否则你将永远坐在这个地方，嗯，是的，那笔债务太疯狂了，是的，但我看到的是，它，甚至对于
mental health workers and things like that we're creating these like robotic entities of people not necessarily shells of people but they they just are so routine and so like accustomed to this bad system that they don't work. Well empiricism connected to no humanity no soul no anything I think is another one of those things that just gets uh it it's not like there's one guy doing it but it does benefit a lot of entities and it has kind of gotten out of control when you're you're saying that it almost like breaks candidates is that what you mean or are there other ways that that happens? No, that's no, that's it. It's just it.
心理健康工作者之类的人来说，我们正在创造这些像机器人一样的实体，不一定是人的空壳，但他们只是太常规了，太习惯于这个糟糕的系统，以至于他们无法工作。嗯，与没有人性、没有灵魂、没有其他任何东西联系在一起的经验主义，我认为这是另一件只会……它不像是一个人在做，但它确实让很多实体受益，而且它已经有点失控了。你说它几乎像打破了候选人，你是这个意思吗？还是有其他方式发生这种情况？不，不，就是这样。就是它。
They fall into the trap. Like you said, they just kind of like. Go throughout the rest of their life, you know, not really exploring how to regain their self inside of it because they don't feel like it's worth it. Right. Because the more and more you branch out and try to regain a passion, there's always something that brings you down again. And that sounds so terrible, but that's the whole point of this is that we have to – like being in a burnout mode isn't bad as long as you process it and try to get through that
他们掉进了陷阱。就像你说的，他们只是，就像。度过余生，你知道，并没有真正探索如何在其中找回自我，因为他们觉得不值得。对。因为你越是扩展并试图找回热情，总会有什么东西再次把你拉下来。这听起来太可怕了，但这就是这一切的重点，我们必须——就像处于倦怠模式并不坏，只要你处理它并试图度过那个难关，
and figuring out what actually is. And I want to, yeah, basically say that. Like being in burnout doesn't mean you're a bad person or that you suck at your job or that everyone else around you sucks. It just means that you're just in a spot where it's like a life cycle. There's some death and rebirth at the end of that.
并弄清楚到底是什么。我想，是的，基本上说出来。就像处于倦怠并不意味着你是一个坏人，或者你的工作做得一团糟，或者你周围的每个人都很糟糕。这只是意味着你处于一个像生命周期一样的位置。在那之后有一些死亡和重生。
Well, I think it's a way of burnout is maybe a general way of thinking about it is that it it does. Yeah, it doesn't mean that you're acting incompetent. A ton of people are like, well, I'm not burned out because I'm not acting incompetently. I'm still doing my job while I'm still functioning. And it's like, yeah, that's great. But burnout is describing that you're coming in through it in a way that is not sustainable.
嗯，我认为这是一种方式，倦怠可能是一种通用的思考方式，它确实。是的，它并不意味着你的行为不称职。很多人会说，嗯，我没有倦怠，因为我的行为没有不称职。我还在工作，我还在运作。就像，是的，那很好。但倦怠是在描述你正在以一种不可持续的方式经历它。
Yeah. So like while you still got a little energy left, let's figure out a plan to make that sustainable. So like, while you still got a little energy left, let's figure out a plan to make that sustainable. Could you, could you go through just like practical tips or techniques that people, um, that you would use with somebody who's in academia, who is an MD, who, um, you know, is an executive who isn't healthcare and they know that that's them, you know, but they're also sitting back and being like, yeah, I, you know some books i've read some podcasts i've heard some podcasts and i know what cbt is i know cbt works so like i don't want to go into therapy and make a list of my emotions and point at my emotion on the pillow or um you know no yeah uh what can you do to help me yeah so you know obviously the mindfulness um based stress reduction kind of things. I think the first is defining it, like in processing the actual burnout in itself, right?
是的。所以，当你还有一点精力时，让我们制定一个计划，使之可持续。所以，当你还有一点精力时，让我们制定一个计划，使之可持续。你能，你能列举一些实际的技巧或方法吗，人们，嗯，你会对那些在学术界、医学博士、嗯，你知道，是医疗保健领域的高管，他们知道那是他们，你知道，但他们也坐在后面说，是的，我，你知道我读过一些书，听过一些播客，我知道什么是CBT（认知行为疗法），我知道CBT有效，所以我不想去接受治疗，列出我的情绪，在枕头上指出我的情绪，或者，你知道，不，是的，呃，你能做什么来帮助我？是的，所以，你知道，显然是基于正念的减压之类的东西。我认为首先是定义它，就像处理倦怠本身一样，对吧？
I think if we, what I see a lot, sorry, I'm going off, but what I see a lot is we start kind of like treating symptoms of burnout and not necessarily actual burnout, right? We treat people operating in an unsustainable system with a kind of treatment that also is not sustainable, you know? Yeah. Like let's say, you know, if I just go, if I just work out five times a week, my stress will be reduced. If, you know, I have low mood, if I start changing my diet, um, and I'll, you know, change my diet, drink less, right. Uh, my mood will improve. Well, those are healthy things, but like you're not processing what's actually causing those things,
我认为如果我们，我看到很多，抱歉，我跑题了，但我看到很多是我们开始，就像治疗倦怠的症状，而不是必然的实际倦怠，对吧？我们用一种同样不可持续的治疗方法来治疗在不可持续系统中运作的人，你知道吗？是的。就像，假设，你知道，如果我只是去，如果我每周锻炼五次，我的压力就会减轻。如果，你知道，我情绪低落，如果我开始改变我的饮食，嗯，我会，你知道，改变我的饮食，少喝酒，对吧。呃，我的情绪会改善。嗯，那些是健康的事情，但你并没有处理是什么真正导致了这些事情，
much like, you know, anxiety and symptoms of trauma after that. You know, we tend to just focus on the symptoms, but not actually the root. And so in getting back to that self of like centering, like it being accepting that it's okay to have burnout, right, getting'm getting that. That's the first part is that acceptance and then running through and having sustainable plans of
就像，你知道，焦虑和创伤后的症状。你知道，我们倾向于只关注症状，而不是真正的根源。所以，回到那种以自我为中心的中心，就像接受倦怠是可以的，对吧，得到那个。这是第一部分，是接受，然后运行并制定可持续的计划，
how to prevent that and reduce your stress. Is it meaning that you can accept one thing at work and then try to do something differently? You don't have to change everything all at once, right. Um, and basically having a good plan in place to kind of recognize like your symptoms of burnout you know whether it's or uh compassion fatigue whether it's somatic you know symptoms or you know you just feel angry all the time it's right it's being able to recognize those things and i think we're not obviously recognizing that type of symptoms in our life. Like we just, we, we, you know, we kind of, our pause, we're like, oh, I'm just so mad, you know, well, how do you get rid of that anger? And it, you know, if you don't know the root of
关于如何预防和减轻你的压力。这是否意味着你可以接受工作中的一件事，然后尝试做一些不同的事情？你不必一次改变所有事情，对吧。嗯，基本上有一个好的计划来识别，就像你的倦怠症状，你知道，无论是，或者呃，同情心疲劳，无论是躯体，你知道，症状，或者，你知道，你只是整天感到愤怒，这是对的，这是能够识别这些事情，我认为我们显然没有在我们的生活中识别那种类型的症状。就像我们只是，我们，我们，你知道，我们有点，我们的暂停，我们就像，哦，我只是太生气了，你知道，好吧，你怎么摆脱那种愤怒？而且，你知道，如果你不知道根源，
the anger, you're never gonna get rid of it. So those obviously CBT things like that are really good. Cause you have to change. One of the things is you have to change your thought process on the system kind of thing, right? And being acceptance, accepting that, you know, your system may not change now. But when you redevelop and find yourself and find your passion again, you're your current change you said just defining the problem I'm thinking of the Joseph Campbell's you know the hero's journey or circle wheel or whatever I think Dan Harmon calls it that but the the first that just naming your pain gives you power enough over it to begin to heal the perspective itself is healing you know oh yeah absolutely
你就永远无法摆脱它。所以那些显然像CBT这样的东西真的很好。因为你必须改变。其中一件事是你必须改变你对系统的思考过程，对吧？并且是接受，接受，你知道，你的系统现在可能不会改变。但当你重新发展并找到自己，再次找到你的热情时，你当前的改变，你说只是定义问题，我想到约瑟夫·坎贝尔（Joseph Campbell）的，你知道，英雄之旅或圆轮之类的，我想丹·哈蒙（Dan Harmon）称之为那个，但第一步，仅仅是命名你的痛苦就给了你足够的力量来开始治愈，视角本身就是治愈，你知道，哦，是的，绝对。
i get umberto echo i think i think that's him and the name of the rose says something about like blessed are the poor for um like at least the rich have the language to know who their enemies are or something like that no um that's across the board of just naming things in general yeah power yeah and and i what i see because i i think i see i've got a couple mds but like more um more kind of like executives i've seen and they're thinking that there's going to be like the the therapist who's like 22 who graduated from like the you know mom and dad paid for college and they have no life experience and they went straight from the sorority to the like small you know christ, Christian master's program. And now they're coming
我得到翁贝托·埃科（Umberto Eco），我想，我想那是他，在《玫瑰的名字》（The Name of the Rose）里说了一些关于，穷人有福了，因为，嗯，至少富人有语言知道谁是他们的敌人之类的，不，嗯，那是关于命名事物的普遍情况，是的，力量，是的，而且我所看到的，因为我，我想我看到，我有几个医学博士，但更多的是，嗯，更多的是，你知道，我见过的高管，他们认为会有像22岁的治疗师，毕业于，你知道，爸爸妈妈付钱上大学，他们没有生活经验，他们直接从联谊会到了，你知道，天哪，基督教硕士课程。现在他们出来了，
out and they, you know, they're just learning how to like decorate an apartment and somebody who has an enormous compromise that they're making all the time with like wealth and power and systems and all this stuff is going to come in and just have no capacity to be understood. And that's what they're afraid of. And but there are therapists who have backgrounds in these things, you know, like you and me, I don't have your background, you know, I have a different background in psych, but like, who can say, Oh, my gosh, yeah, the system is changing so much, like the world that you thought healthier, you thought you were going to be in when you were going in when you were a kid is not there anymore. And now you're starting to accept that and grieve that and where do you think it'll be in five years and how can you prepare for that you know just somebody who can
他们，你知道，他们只是在学习如何装饰公寓，而一个一直在财富、权力和系统以及所有这些东西上做出巨大妥协的人要进来，却完全没有能力被理解。这就是他们害怕的。但确实有背景在这些方面的治疗师，你知道，像你和我，我没有你的背景，你知道，我在心理学方面有不同的背景，但像，谁能说，哦，天哪，是的，系统变化太大了，就像你认为的医疗保健世界，当你还是个孩子时你认为你会进入的世界已经不存在了。现在你开始接受并哀悼这一点，你认为五年后它会变成什么样，你如何为之做准备，你知道，只是一个能
have that kind of conversation and and systemic perspective is like something you can't see when you're just in it all the time you know and it's like too scary to look down yeah and the conversations i've had with you like it seems like that that seems like it might just be most of what changes in the first session is that somebody's like oh you're right like i'm allowed to think this i'm allowed to see that i'm allowed to label these things you know yeah um no yeah it's you know i didn't think talking about that basically burnout and compassion fatigue uh you would think that that would like ruin me you know just hearing all of the the problems of the system um but uh i don't know the best problems you know it's not like we're not saying healthcare is bad you know you know people still
进行那种对话并具有系统视角的人，是你一直身处其中时无法看到的，你知道，而且看起来太可怕了，不敢往下看。是的，我和你进行的对话，看起来这似乎可能只是第一次会议中改变的大部分，就是有人说，哦，你是对的，就像我被允许这样想，我被允许看到这一点，我被允许标记这些事情，你知道，是的，嗯，不，是的，你知道，我没想到谈论那个，基本上是倦怠和同情心疲劳，你会认为那会毁了我，你知道，只是听到系统所有的这些问题，但是，嗯，我不知道，最好的问题，你知道，这不像我们不是在说医疗保健很糟糕，你知道，你知道人们仍然
have to be doctors people still have to be you know it's understanding them you know yeah and it's giving a safe space for it i I mean, just imagine, especially in residency, when you're about to, you're not an attending yet, and you have to, who do you complain to? We're not complaining, but who do you even reach out? If you tell all your cohort or your attendings that you're facing burnout as a resident, what can that do to you as a person? You wouldn't want to do that. It kind of closes some doors for you. Well, and it's political too, in a way that you can't be terribly vulnerable with the people who might understand what you're talking about. I mean, I think academia is lonely for the same reason
必须是医生，人们仍然必须是，你知道，这是理解他们，你知道，是的，而且这是为它提供一个安全的空间。我的意思是，试想一下，特别是在住院医师实习期间，当你即将，你还不是主治医生，你必须，你向谁抱怨？我们不是在抱怨，但你甚至向谁求助？如果你告诉所有的同僚或主治医生，你作为住院医师正面临倦怠，那会对你个人造成什么影响？你不会想那样做的。这在某种程度上为你关闭了一些门。嗯，而且它也是政治性的，以一种你不能对那些可能理解你在说什么的人表现得非常脆弱的方式。我的意思是，我认为学术界很孤独，原因相同，
is that it's like, okay, let's take all the people in the world who know enough about this teeny tiny little thing, area of oncology or you know like medieval texts or whatever and then we'll put them in like we'll and then we'll make them all compete against each other so it's like everybody who who could be my friend man i'm kind of you know like that's the thing academics navigate you know health care is political in a different way there's not that kind of direct competition but yet you can't be super vulnerable i mean you you know you're you're kind of a politician in a hospital oh yeah and you you know, you're kind of a politician in a hospital. Oh, yeah. And then, you know,
就是，好吧，让我们把世界上所有对这个微小的东西，肿瘤学领域或者你知道，中世纪文本之类的东西了解得足够多的人都找来，然后我们把他们放在，就像，我们把他们放在一起，然后让他们互相竞争，所以就像每一个可能成为我朋友的人，伙计，我有点，你知道，这就是学者们导航的东西，你知道，医疗保健在不同的方面是政治性的，没有那种直接的竞争，但你仍然不能表现得超级脆弱，我的意思是，你，你知道，你，你有点像医院里的政客。哦，是的，而且你，你知道，你有点像医院里的政客。哦，是的。然后，你知道，
then you get kind of paranoid because the moment that you feel like you're your that you feel this certain way, you know, you feel like somebody is going to step over you to get ahead because they're saying, well, they can't handle that right now. They're in a tough space. And that's not for everyone. That's not everyone that I come in contact with. But you can just imagine, yeah,
然后你变得有点偏执，因为当你觉得你，你觉得这种特定的方式时，你知道，你觉得有人会为了领先而踩过你，因为他们会说，好吧，他们现在处理不了那个。他们处于一个艰难的空间。那不是每个人。那不是我接触到的每个人。但你可以想象，是的，
the political nature of everything of, of wanting to succeed. You know, you're not in your peak of your career just yet. So you have to gain, you're still gaining and you're still trying to win. The social work thing is kind of, you know,
一切的政治本质，想要成功。你知道，你还没有达到职业生涯的巅峰。所以你必须获得，你还在获得，你还在试图赢。社会工作的事情有点，你知道，
like you go to school, if you have a bachelor's, then the, the master's degrees, you know, two years, and then you get out of it and then you have to work for something. You can't take insurance. You're not very useful. So, or you're
就像你上学，如果你有学士学位，那么，硕士学位，你知道，两年，然后你出来，然后你必须为某事工作。你不能接受保险。你不是很有用。所以，或者你
not very profitable. So you're working in these places that have a lot of problems. A lot of the more toxic people never get out of that level of practice. And the first two, three years of social work practice is like pretty chaotic for most people. And then you can get the LIC and you can get out but that like that is draining like working with i work with a lot of social workers and just preparing for like how to do it how to go through it to know this isn't going to last forever to stay motivated to study for the licsw so you're not there for six years you know yeah we do that a ton but for doctors i mean that's like that's almost a decade by the time you're going through school and
不是很赚钱。所以你在这些有很多问题的地方工作。很多更具毒性的人永远不会离开那个实践水平。社会工作实践的前两三年对大多数人来说是相当混乱的。然后你可以获得执照（LICSW），你可以离开，但那，那很耗费精力，就像与，我与很多社会工作者一起工作，只是准备，如何做，如何度过它，知道这不会永远持续下去，保持动力去学习LICSW，这样你就不会在那里待上六年，你知道，是的，我们经常这样做，但对于医生，我的意思是，那几乎是十年，当你经历学校和
resident i mean you you don't even know who you're going to be on the other side of that and i think therapy is indicated when you're going through a change where you forget who you are you know yeah or might you know lose touch with it no it's it's a it's a wild it's a wild party for the for the mds and um i mean like i said third-year med students don't even know what medicine they're going to be in i ask them every week you know what medicine are you going into and in. I ask them every week, you know, what medicine are you going into? And they'll say, well, I haven't figured that out yet. And it's just like, well, I mean, you're coming close to it, but if they can't even know what, you know, what profession that they want to pick, and this is not on them at all. This is just, they're still in a spot where they're trying to figure out themselves, and it's really hard to combat.
住院医师实习时，我的意思是，你甚至不知道在那之后你会成为谁，我认为当你经历一个你忘记了你是谁的变化时，治疗是必要的，你知道，是的，或者可能，你知道，失去联系。不，它是一个，它是一个疯狂的，它是一个疯狂的派对，对于医学博士来说，而且，嗯，我的意思是，就像我说的，三年级医学生甚至不知道他们将从事什么医学专业。我每周都问他们，你知道，你打算从事什么医学专业？在。我每周都问他们，你知道，你打算从事什么医学专业？他们会说，好吧，我还没弄清楚。就像，好吧，我的意思是，你快要接近它了，但如果他们甚至不知道，你知道，他们想选择什么职业，这根本不是他们的错。这只是，他们仍然处于一个试图弄清楚自己的位置，而且真的很难对抗。
Like, I'm trying to figure this out, but I'm also burning out at the same time like so it's a it's it's sad and like I said it's not just them like yeah it is academics and and even you know mental health and social workers I mean they they do have those rough jobs I mean I experienced that with community mental health I mean it's great and you do learn a lot but when you stuck, because the person that you're helping is limited by a parent or something like, you know, I worked with children a good bit. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. Not. Yeah. Well, I loved it. And I still do. I'll revisit that. That's part of my burnout is,
就像，我正在努力弄清楚这一点，但我同时也感到倦怠，所以这是一个，这是一个悲伤的事情，就像我说的，不仅仅是他们，就像，是的，它是学术界，甚至，你知道，心理健康和社会工作者，我的意思是，他们确实有那些艰苦的工作，我的意思是，我在社区心理健康中体验过这一点，我的意思是，这很棒，你确实学到了很多，但当你被困住时，因为你正在帮助的人受到父母或什么的限制，你知道，我与孩子们一起工作过一段时间。我做不到。我做不到。不。是的。嗯，我喜欢它。而且我仍然喜欢。我会重温那个。那是我的倦怠的一部分，
you know, I'm taking some time and realizing that I had to take a break. One of the biggest things in community mental health and children services was that these children get better but as soon as like the parents stops engaging with that type of work kids don't get better and seeing that over and over again really takes a toll on you and so I've set back you know I've just kind of said you know I'll give it some years before I revisit children and working with them. And I'll still work with them now, but like on a small, you know, tiny basis. But it is.
你知道，我花了一些时间，意识到我必须休息一下。在社区心理健康和儿童服务中，最大的事情之一是这些孩子好转了，但一旦父母停止参与那种工作，孩子就不会好转，一次又一次地看到这一点真的会让你付出代价，所以我退后了，你知道，我只是有点说，你知道，我会给它几年时间，然后再重温儿童和与他们一起工作。我现在仍然会和他们一起工作，但就像在小，你知道，微小的基础上。但它是。
I just when I was doing individual therapy and they kept trying to put me with kids because I was male. And there's a lot of people that there weren't very many male therapists at the big at the big practice that I was at before Taproot. And so like I was talking to one of the child therapists when i finally was like do not give me another teenager like i i can't do it because they would always be like no no there's no family problems with this one it's fine it's a wealthy family and they have this they just he's just having a little trouble whatever and i'd be on the phone with the hr until two in the morning and then the case would blow up and then of course i'm gonna come back to individual therapy or something and I was talking to one of the child
我只是，当我做个人治疗时，他们一直试图把我安排给孩子，因为我是男性。在我去Taproot之前，我在那个大型诊所里没有很多男性治疗师。所以，就像我终于和其中一位儿童治疗师谈话时，我说不要再给我一个青少年了，就像我，我做不到，因为他们总是会说，不，不，这个没有家庭问题，没关系，这是一个富裕的家庭，他们有这个，他只是有点小麻烦，无论什么，我会和人力资源部通电话直到凌晨两点，然后案件就会爆发，然后当然我会回到个人治疗之类的，我正在和其中一位儿童
therapists and I was like because all he did was trauma with children and I was like look I can't do this like I can take a 40 year old and say let's go back to when you're 12 and when we go back to when you're 12 let's heal that right yeah but I don't want to take a 12 year old and say all right yeah let's use in mindfulness and I'm going to be here with you and i love you and i care about you but you're just going to have to go back into this house where the problems don't change for the next six years like i can't do that yeah and he was like oh i love that he was like that's why i do it is because i get to be there with him and it's like i was wild i realized like so many people have different skills than me in that conversation and are looking at things from this different angle as i was trying to solve a problem and he was trying to be there in the middle of
治疗师谈话，我说，因为他所做的只是儿童创伤，我说，看，我做不到这一点，就像我可以带一个40岁的人说，让我们回到你12岁的时候，当我们回到你12岁的时候，让我们治愈那个，对吧，是的，但我不想带一个12岁的人说，好吧，是的，让我们使用正念，我会在这里陪着你，我爱你，我关心你，但你只是不得不回到这个家里，问题在接下来的六年里不会改变，就像我做不到那样，是的，他说，哦，我喜欢那个，他说，这就是我做它的原因，因为我能和他们在一起，就像，我意识到，就像很多人在那个对话中拥有与我不同的技能，并从这个不同的角度看待事物，当我试图解决一个问题时，他试图在痛苦中陪伴，
pain you know that he couldn't change and I think that's much more yeah you know I don't know it was it was wild but I take yeah it that skill set I uh I'm so glad we have such a diverse kind of like skills across you know therapists and social workers and things like that, just because I'm glad that some people enjoy that type of work. Um, but it, it, I wonder, I haven't,
他无法改变，我认为那更，是的，你知道，我不知道，那很疯狂，但我接受，是的，那套技能，我，我很高兴我们在治疗师和社会工作者等之间有如此多样化的技能，只是因为我很高兴有些人喜欢那种工作。嗯，但它，它，我想知道，我还没有，
I haven't met anybody who has said, oh man, I'll, I'll work with kids forever. Right. And, and I'm waiting, I mean,
我还没有遇到过谁说，哦，伙计，我会，我会永远和孩子们一起工作。对。而且，而且我在等，我的意思是，
I'm sure there's somebody out there. I just haven't met anybody. And I really want to pick their brain. It's like, you know, wow. Um, and there's some great people who, especially the kids who kind of need a lot of work.
我相信外面有这样的人。我只是还没遇到过。而且我真的很想探究他们的想法。就像，你知道，哇。嗯，有一些很棒的人，特别是那些需要很多工作的孩子。
I mean, there's some kids who come out on top. And to this day, I have, you know, clients that I saw, you know, eight years ago that are 24 and they're 16. And I see them and they've done really well. And, you know, and I've asked them, you know, you know, you're doing well. How, why? And, or not why, but, you know, we worked on you for a long time.
我的意思是，有些孩子脱颖而出。直到今天，我有，你知道，我八年前看到的客户，他们24岁了，他们16岁。我看到他们，他们做得很好。而且，你知道，我问过他们，你知道，你做得很好。怎么，为什么？或者不是为什么，但是，你知道，我们为你工作了很长时间。
And, you know, what's, and it's, I got out of the house, you know, or I left, I went to, you know, and that's just, I mean, that's wild. I mean, just think if, when you're working with a 12 year, yeah, 12 year old, you've got six years before you have the opportunity to leave the house. And I liked family work. I mean, when the whole
而且，你知道，什么是，而且是，我离开了那个家，你知道，或者我离开了，我去了，你知道，那只是，我的意思是，那很疯狂。我的意思是，试想一下，当你和一个12岁，是的，12岁的人一起工作时，你有六年时间才有机会离开那个家。而且我喜欢家庭工作。我的意思是，当整个
family's there, which Becky Mills said in our practice says that and she's really good at involving the family and getting everyone to communicate. But it's like, when you when you have like, the parents are like, I don't know how to do this. I want to understand what the child's emotion means. Or how can I do a parent plan? That's a whole nother thing. I mean, now I was doing it, it was someone was bringing a child to individual therapy and basically being like make them stop doing this i'm gonna change nothing and it's like well you're you're in the counter all right i don't know what i'm supposed to do like i it wasn't for me um when the family wants to change that's wonderful um yeah too many of the especially like the child diagnoses
家庭都在那里时，贝基·米尔斯（Becky Mills）在我们的诊所里说，她真的很擅长让家庭参与进来，让每个人都沟通。但就像，当你拥有，就像，父母说，我不知道该怎么做。我想了解孩子的这种情绪意味着什么。或者我怎么能制定一个父母计划？那是另一回事。我的意思是，现在我正在做，有人带孩子来做个人治疗，基本上是说，让他们停止这样做，我什么都不会改变，就像，好吧，你处于反面，好吧，我不知道我应该做什么，就像，它不适合我，当家庭想要改变时，那太棒了，是的，太多的，特别是像儿童诊断，
well i know i mean no the whole thing but it affects children in a different way we just we've moved like especially even like the dsm has moved further away from the icd-10-11 because it wants to concentrate on how american wants americans want to do research and not really like what how what the symptom is but just the way we want to conceive of it or as useful for our system to conceive of it. And part of that has just taken away the focus on the environment at all and try to be like every, every symptom is just sort of happening genetically or by bacterially in
嗯，我知道，我的意思是，不，整件事，但它以不同的方式影响孩子，我们只是，我们已经移动了，就像特别是甚至像DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）已经进一步远离了ICD-10-11，因为它想专注于美国人想要如何做研究，而不是真正地，就像症状是什么，而只是我们想要构想它的方式，或者对我们的系统构想它是有用的。而这其中的一部分已经完全消除了对环境的关注，并试图说，每一个，每一个症状都只是在某种程度上在基因上或细菌上发生，在
somebody's head. And with the child diagnosis, I can't even read some of these new ones that got asked when they do some five, you're just like, they're like, Oh, you know, the child totally not the parent's fault that it does that disorder yeah like why did you add this um and i don't know um so can you say anything about like those systems like the way that we don't really want to critique an environment but we put more and
某人的脑子里。而且对于儿童诊断，我甚至读不懂一些这些新的，当他们做一些五的时候，你只是像，他们就像，哦，你知道，孩子完全不是父母的错，它有那个障碍，是的，就像你为什么要添加这个，而且我不知道，嗯，所以你能说些什么关于，像那些系统，我们并不真正想批评环境，但我们投入更多，
more responsibility on the individual like in a way that's breaking health care do you see that like i don't know um if that's relevant to stuff that you see um actually say that again like the the way that i think it's like useful for health care to put more and more like responsibility that isn't fair on the provider to like fix an environment that they have no control over, you know, oh, yeah, I mean That's the thing. So Prince. Yeah, I see that all and that is relevant Mainly because it there are really good Docs and I don't I don't think they're in burnout But let's say let's say a trauma surgeon You know, they have three days to basically discharge a person from their bed yeah and and you're talking
把更多责任推给个人，某种程度上正在摧毁医疗保健系统，你觉得是这样吗？我不知道这和你所见的情况是否相关。其实，你能再说一遍吗？我认为医疗保健系统越来越倾向于把不公平的责任推给医疗提供者，让他们去修复一个他们根本无法控制的环境，你知道吗？哦，是的，我的意思是，确实如此。所以，普林斯，是的，我完全看到了这一点，这确实相关，主要是因为确实有非常优秀的医生，我不认为他们处于倦怠状态，但假设，假设是一位创伤外科医生，你知道，他们基本上只有三天时间让病人出院，是的，而且你正在谈论
about a wide range of a wide range of trauma uh physical trauma that you know it could be a gunshot wound it could be someone that has 90 burns but the way that their system is set up is in insurance it's just like we need that bed in three days yeah yeah and and that isn't the doctor's fault as an individual you know it may be the ama's fault as as an entity made of doctors but that isn't this one person's yeah it's it's insurance as well um and so yeah it it's not that doctor's fault but that the doctor has to do i mean they can stretch it but i, there's incentives for that 3A rule kind of thing. I'm not entirely sure how it works out, but then again, you know, if they're medically, you know, clear, it's just like, well, they can discharge home. Well, are you discharging a,
各种各样的创伤，身体创伤，你知道，可能是枪伤，也可能是烧伤面积达90%的病人，但他们的系统设置和保险要求就是，我们三天内就需要那张床位，是的，是的，而且作为个人，这并不是医生的错，你知道，这可能是作为医生组成的实体——美国医学会（AMA）的错，但那并不是这一个人的错，是的，这也是保险的问题，所以是的，那不是医生的错，但医生必须去做，我的意思是他们可以尽量拖延，但为了那种“三天规则”之类的东西，是有激励机制的。我不完全确定它是怎么运作的，但话说回来，你知道，如果他们医疗上已经达标了，就像，好吧，他们可以出院回家了。那么，你是在把一个
you know, person without a home to the streets with 90% burns? Like that's, that's wild. And our system in our state is not set up to really help out that population. And I say that all the time. It's like we can't, you know, I say this, you can't think about this because you can't work harder than our system allows. Specifically the state system. There's literally no resources for that type of population. And so, yeah, and that's out of their control. That's not even part.
你知道，无家可归的人，带着90%的烧伤送回街头吗？这太离谱了。我们州的系统并没有设置好去真正帮助那个人群。我一直都在说这个。就像我们不能，你知道，我这么说，你不能考虑这个，因为你不能比我们系统允许的更努力地工作。特别是州系统。对于那类人群，确实没有任何资源。所以，是的，这超出了他们的控制范围。这甚至不是他们的一部分。
I mean, that's Alabama politics at that. And I say that all the time. Why don't we just march down to Montgomery and try to fix it? Well, backlash, you know, I've come conspiracy theories on that. And I'm not talking bad about it. I mean, you know, I love Alabama.
我的意思是，那是阿拉巴马州的政治问题。我一直都在说。为什么我们不直接游行到蒙哥马利去尝试解决它呢？嗯，会有反弹，你知道，我对此有一些阴谋论。我不是在说坏话。我的意思是，你知道，我爱阿拉巴马。
It's just, we are, you know, I wish the awareness there for that type of, those types of interactions need to be seen. I mean, cause that puts a toll on all these, you know, whether it's nursing staff or the social workers, working these families have to figure out, you know, Oh my God, like this patient's ready to go. What do we do? Well, I think politics has used more of a scapegoat than a solution.
只是，我们是，你知道，我希望人们能意识到这类互动需要被看到。我的意思是，因为这给所有这些人带来了负担，你知道，无论是护理人员还是社会工作者，处理这些家庭的问题，他们必须弄清楚，你知道，天哪，这个病人准备好了，我们该怎么办？嗯，我认为政治被用作替罪羊的次数多于被用作解决方案的次数。
I mean, I'm like thinking of all this stuff that like happens on my Instagram. It'll just be, somebody will like film a homeless person in like California or Portland and then be like, Democrats do this. And you're like, I'm in a red state,
我的意思是，我想到所有这些发生在我Instagram上的事情。通常就是，有人会拍一个加州或波特兰的无家可归者，然后说，民主党人造成了这样。你会觉得，我是在一个红州，
man. You want me to, you want a video? Like what, what, what is your solution to this? It doesn't look like anyone's doing much, you know?
伙计。你想要我，你想要一个视频？就像，你对此的解决方案是什么？看起来没人做太多事，你知道吗？
Yeah. So yeah, I mean, I think the politics is, is something that is bipartisanly not, not, I mean, I think the politics is, is something that is bipartisanly, um, not, not, uh, not effective, you know? And, and, and a lot of my colleagues, I mean, they get to the point where, you know, they, if they try to, you know, stick their neck out and try to give a different alternative solution, I mean, they're, they're like hammered down,
是的。所以，是的，我的意思是，我认为政治是，是某种两党都不，不，我的意思是，我认为政治是，是某种两党都不，嗯，不，不，不有效的东西，你知道吗？而且，而且，我的很多同事，我的意思是，他们到了那种地步，你知道，如果他们尝试，你知道，挺身而出，尝试提供另一种替代方案，我的意思是，他们会被狠狠地打压，
like, no, that's not, no, we can't keep this person two more days no you gotta figure out a way to get them out especially our social work colleagues at uab i mean i i sorry the hospital workout yeah um so it's on you man i don't work there anymore i love it but it's just like there's so much there that uh they they do work hard and they do try hard uh but they're i mean it's expected of them to like get this person out get them do this but if they can't it's it seems like it's that social worker that you know that case manager's problem but it's not i mean they're literally hands are tied behind their back to where they are and that gets a lot of people into that space of just like this is nothing i
就像，不，不行，我们不能让这个人多住两天，你必须想办法让他们出院，特别是我们在UAB的社会工作同事，我的意思是，我，抱歉，医院的工作，是的，嗯，所以这取决于你，伙计，我不在那里工作了，我喜欢它，但只是那里有太多东西，他们确实工作很努力，他们也确实很尽力，但他们，我的意思是，人们期望他们把这个人弄出去，让他们做这个，但如果他们做不到，看起来这就是那个社会工作者，你知道，那个个案经理的问题，但事实并非如此，我的意思是，他们的手实际上被绑在背后，他们无能为力，这让很多人陷入了那种“这没什么，我
don't care about not necessarily i don't care about the person anymore but like if this is all we got this is all we got and yeah like i said that robotic they just they just one track mind just keep going right they just do what's asked of them um i think that culture is changing at you know the hospital with having to realize that you know we have a little bit more power to say like no um and right now there's not like to say no to like bad plans um and i have to kind of like walk you know people through those plans of like what's better you know what's better for the patient what's better for you um mainly because yeah i't know. My colleagues, they endure so much. That's one reason why I want is awareness to burnout and compassion fatigue, just because the system and
不在乎”的状态，不一定是我不再关心那个人了，而是如果这就是我们所能做的全部，这就是我们所能做的全部，是的，就像我说的，那种机械化，他们只是，他们只是单向思维，一直往前走，对吧？他们只是做被要求做的事，嗯，我认为这种文化正在改变，你知道，在医院里，人们开始意识到，你知道，我们有更多一点权力去说“不”，而且现在并没有说“不”去拒绝糟糕计划的渠道，我必须引导人们去了解那些计划，比如什么对病人更好，什么对你更好，主要是因为，是的，我不知道。我的同事们，他们忍受了太多。这就是为什么我想要提高对倦怠和同情疲劳的认识，仅仅是因为这个系统和
where we are, it's a great place to be. But I mean, we are not immune to that type of... Well, and I don't think that a lot of the problems that you're talking about are unique to something that UAB is doing or that even healthcare at this point is doing i mean a lot of uh this stuff you can read stuff from you know the 70s or the 40s and the the in the bureaucratic insecurity is the same you know it's like because the bigger and or what's the there's like a joke that we always make about how like they put up the posters in the school. They're like, don't take our word for it. Think outside the box, like never stop learning how it actually works, you know.
我们所处的地方，这是一个很好的地方。但我的意思是，我们对那种……嗯，我不认为你谈论的很多问题是UAB所独有的，或者甚至是医疗保健目前所独有的，我的意思是，很多这些东西，你可以读到70年代或40年代的东西，官僚主义的不安全感是一样的，你知道，就像因为规模越大，或者是什么，我们总是开玩笑说他们如何在学校里张贴海报。他们说，不要只听我们的一面之词。要跳出框框思考，永远不要停止学习它是如何真正运作的，你知道。
And then if you do any of the things that are on the posters on the wall of the elementary school, like you will be an alternative school. Like you have to put it on the poster. Like, don't do that, kids. You know, and the hospital's kind of the same in that a bigger bureaucracy gets. I'm thinking of, I really like the HBO Chernobyl show. It was really good. But you get that sort of end of the USSR insecurity of like,
然后如果你真的做了小学墙上海报上的任何事情，比如你会被送去替代学校。就像你必须把它贴在海报上。就像，孩子们，不要那样做。你知道，医院也差不多，官僚机构越大越是这样。我想到，我真的很喜欢HBO的《切尔诺贝利》剧集。它真的很棒。但你会得到那种苏联末期的不安全感，就像，
but you're saying, yeah, you make a very good point and you have lots of evidence, but you're saying that the party is wrong and the only problem is the party can't be wrong. So you must be in trouble you know there but you get that where it's just like i remember being in these meetings that they would make us go to that would go on forever and they were like we really want to have a solution we really want to do things different we really want to improve and we need y'all's feedback so could you you give us some like advice? And but the but the only thing was you couldn't say that they weren't perfect. Right.
但你说，是的，你提出了一个很好的观点，你有很多证据，但你是在说党是错的，而唯一的问题是党不能是错的。所以你一定有麻烦了，你知道，在那里，但你会得到那种情况，就像我记得参加那些他们强迫我们参加的会议，那些会议没完没了，他们说我们真的想有一个解决方案，我们真的想做不同的事情，我们真的想改进，我们需要你们的反馈，所以你们能给我们一些建议吗？但是，但是唯一的要求是你不能说他们不完美。对吧。
And you couldn't say that something needed to change. So that was the unspoken rule. So I was always like, especially when I knew that I was going to be in private practice here, I was always like, OK, if you do these things, doctors will burn out less. You will make more money. There will be less met errors. There will be less staff turnover. And the downside is that somebody might not like that you change something who hasn't worked here
而且你不能说有些事情需要改变。所以那是潜规则。所以我总是，特别是当我意识到我将在这里从事私人执业时，我总是说，好吧，如果你做这些事情，医生会减少倦怠。你会赚更多的钱。医疗错误会减少。员工流动率会降低。而缺点是，有人可能不喜欢你改变了某些事情，那些在这里工作了13年的人，然后他们会在最后过来，就像，你为什么要那样说？你知道，我们要求你的反馈，但你不能说那样的话，你不能，是的，因为他们想要，你知道，满屋子的人说，我们应该有更多的胆识和正直，是的，不，我也参加过这种会议，你只是尝试提出一个解决方案，而你的解决方案是那种比较昂贵的，这也是问题所在，这一切，我不想说这完全是关于钱，但就像归根结底，医学博士对执行层如何运作公司完全没有控制权。而且，嗯，这很疯狂，因为，你知道，解决方案是，你知道，雇佣这种类型的专家或者做这个，
for 13 years and then they would come at the end and be like why did you say that you know we asked for your feedback but you can't say things like that you can't yeah and because they wanted you know a room full of people to be like we should have more gumption and more integrity yeah no and i've been part yeah part of this meeting as well you just you try to come up with a solution and your solution is like kind of the costlier one and that's the thing too it's all i don't want to say it's all about money but like it comes down to mds have no control over and like executives kind of like how the company just functions as a whole. And, uh, it's wild because, you know, the solution is, you know, hire this type of specialist or do this,
你知道，你们在问错人要解决方案了。为什么你们不，你知道，为什么你们不问对人要解决方案呢？我们不想问那些人。对。然后那些，我真的参加过一百人的会议，在UAB头脑风暴某个话题。而在六个月内，他们就直接关闭了它。嗯，退伍军人事务部（VA）在这方面也很有名，
you know, y'all are asking the wrong people for the solutions. Why are you not, you know, why are you not asking the right people for the solutions? We don't want to ask those people. Right. And then those I've literally been in a hundred person meeting, brainstorming a certain topic at UAB. And within six months, it's just, they shut it down. Well, the VA is kind of notorious for that too,
我认为VA可能是最邪恶的官僚机构，就像每次你听说，我的意思是，我记得你可以查一下，就像有时我会谷歌我想知道的东西。就像，我想上一次是，我当时想，
which I think the VA is probably the most nefarious kind of bureaucracy is it's like every time you ever heard, I mean, I remember you can look up, like sometimes I'll be Googling something that I want to know. Like, I think the last one was like, I was like,
哦，我想知道是否有人曾经把龙与地下城（D&D）应用到创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）上，就像是否有人说过你可以角色扮演之类的，我搜索了一下，就像，是的，好吧，这里有一个人为VA做试点研究的人，他取得了巨大的成功，他们正在发表论文，那是在1992年左右，而且那种事情总是会发生，因为那个特定的案例很有趣，申请这个的人可能是一个有趣的剧集，如果我们能找到做那个的人，但他们确实喜欢，嗯，他们会采取，那是，那是孩子们，因为那是家庭项目之类的，但他们会带那些有这种真正负面自我形象的孩子，让他们做那种
Oh, I wonder if anyone's ever applied D and D to PTSDd like if anyone's ever said like you can role play or whatever and i searched it and it's like yeah okay here's a guy who's doing a pilot study for the va who's had wild success and they're publishing the paper and it's like in 1992 or something and like that will always happen where like because that particular case is kind of interesting that the people were applying this might be a fun episode if we could find somebody who does that but they they do like um they would take it was it was kids um where they would because it was like family program or something but they would take kids that had this real negative self-image and make them do like a
团队和D&D，你正在描述你的行动，就像龙与地下城，你正在描述你的行动，所以孩子们必须像，我变得非常生气，我做了这个，然后现在他们在思考情绪，他们就像，好吧，你变得生气并做了那个，实际上只是搞砸了你的团队，是的，然后他们的自我形象会改变，他们会像，我讨厌他，但我有自制力，所以我不会做那件事，你知道，然后，嗯，就像那是那种迷人的事情，但你知道，有氯胺酮、裸盖菇素，有无数种基于大脑的医学，有趣的心理干预，不是CBT，还有成吨成吨的苯二氮卓类药物，是的，嗯，已经做过了，你可以谷歌那个医生做的TED演讲，我的意思是，它实际上可以追溯到1985年，我的意思是，2000年代有很多，没有一个改变了VA
team and dnd you're describing your action like dungeons and dragons you're describing your action so the kids would have to be like i get so angry i do this and then now they're thinking about emotion and they're like well you're getting angry and doing that actually just messed your team up yeah and then their self image would change and they would be like i hate him but i have self-control so i don't do the thing you know and then um like it was like this kind of fascinating thing but you know there's ketamine psilocybin there's a bazillion kind of brain-based medicine interesting psych interventions that aren't cbt and tons and tons of benzos yeah um that have been done and you can google the ted talk that the doctor did and i mean it literally goes back to like 1985 to i mean a ton of them in the 2000s none of them ever changed the way that the va
行医的方式，那种方式，它仍然是CBT和成吨的苯二氮卓类药物用于心理和PTSD，人们被诊断出患有PTSD。他们甚至没有患病。他们只是有点焦虑之类的。所以他们说的那些我们真的想做并改变的事情，从来没有变得足够大来改变系统，即使它上了全国新闻，成就了某人的职业生涯，发表了一堆文章，并被所有研究验证了。
practice medicine the the way that it's done it's still cT and tons of benzos for psych and PTSD and people getting diagnosed with PTSD. They don't even have it. They're just a little anxious or something. And so none of those things that they said, we really want to do it and change ever got big enough to do the system, even though it got national news and made somebody's career and had a bunch of publishing and was validated by all the research.
所以为什么，你知道，为什么，为什么不呢？你知道，我昨天收到了那封邮件。并被所有研究验证了。所以为什么，为什么不呢？我昨天收到了那封邮件，拜登就像，你的计划在我的桌子上，做一个研究。如果你做到了，有所有的奖金，我的意思是，他们每五年做一次
So why, you know, why, why not? You know, I got the email yesterday. and was validated by all the research. So why, why not? I got the email yesterday, Biden was like, your plans on my desk, do a study. There's all this prize money if you, I mean, they do that every five years
而且它并没有改变那个系统。为什么会这样？是的，研究那种系统与像UAB这样的系统会非常有趣。谢天谢地，我们坐在会诊精神病学部门，我很高兴我学到了这么多。这就像玩过家家，就像《豪斯医生》那部剧。我们坐在桌子旁，这是会诊精神病学。所以医疗部门里有人可能正在经历某种危机，我们必须弄清楚。
and it doesn't change that system. Why is that? Yeah, that'd be very interesting to look into that type of system versus a system like UAB. Thankfully, we sit on consult psychiatry, and I'm glad I'm learning so much. It's like playing house, like the show House. We sit around this table, and it's consult psychiatry. So there's someone in medical that's probably having some crisis, and we've got to figure it out.
而且经历这一切并试图弄清楚问题到底是什么，这很疯狂。每个人在很多事情上都依赖心理学，好的病史，嘿，让这个人表现得好一点之类的。而且我认为医院开始只是把心理学理解为“我们不喜欢这个人正在做的事情，叫心理学”。而且就像，这是一个精神病学问题吗？这是一个，就像，它是什么？为什么我们不应该把所有精神病学设施和心理服务称为行为医疗保健的原因之一，因为是的，行为是
And just going through everything and trying to figure out exactly the problem is wild. And everybody leans on psych for a lot of things, good histories and hey, make this person behave kind of thing. And I think hospitals are starting to just take psych to mean like we don't like what this person is doing, call psych. And it's like, is it a psychiatric issue is it a bit like what what is it one of the reasons why maybe we shouldn't call psychiatric all psychiatric facilities and psych services behavioral health care because yeah behavior is
不是，嗯，也许区分一个反社会者和一个精神分裂症患者的最好方法，是的，我的意思是，从个人经验来看，我的意思是，我在2020年做了一个鼻子手术，我从麻醉中醒来，我感到困惑，我赤身裸体地走出了恢复室，试图找到我的衣服，谢天谢地，我当时还在UAB，但就像门诊，如果我是住院病人并做了那样的事，他们会叫心理学，直到，是的，把我带回房间，是的，寻求药物，是的，我当时很困惑，当他们不得不，就像带给我我的衣服，他们就像，嘿，你能帮他回到他的房间吗？而我只是在找衣服，因为我没有，我很困惑，我不记得任何那件事，那只是故事的一部分，但嗯，我，我认为在经济上和最后，有
is not um maybe the best way to separate uh you know somebody who is a sociopath from somebody who has schizophrenia yeah i mean from personal experience i mean i had a like a nose procedure done in 2020 and i woke up from being under and i was like confused and i walked out the recovery room naked trying to find my clothes and thankfully i was in i was still part of uab but like an outpatient had i been inpatient and did that they would have called psych until yeah get me back to the room yeah drug seeking yeah i was so confused when i had to like bring me my my clothes and they're like hey can you just help like get him back into his room and i'm just like searching for clothes because i didn't have i was confused i don't remember any of that that was just kind of the story but well i i think economically and the end of the there's
经济因素和结构因素，但同时我们构思心理学的方式也在改变，希望回到，嗯，某种认知革命之前的一些东西，那正在成为医疗保健的一部分，但，嗯，一件好事，我的意思是，如果你是一名医生，如果你是一名住院医师，一件令人兴奋的事情是，这个系统已经崩溃且无法运作，所以它必须有所不同，就像这不可能再持续衰退10年了，就像有人必须进来，就像我们需要能够建立这些结构，而且，是的，你知道，也许你处于这个你不想待的地方，或者也许你处于这个职业中非常不方便的地方，但它，那也非常令人兴奋。你知道，就像，我们往往不会修复系统，直到它们完全无法修复，直到它们
economic factors and structural factors but then also just the way we conceive of psych is changing and hopefully going back to uh sort of the way some stuff was you know before the cognitive revolution and and that's becoming part of health care but um one good thing i mean one thing that's maybe exciting if you're a doctor if you're a resident is like this system is broken and not working and so it has to be different like there's no way for this to continue to decline for another 10 years like someone's going to have to come in like we need to be able to build these structures and like yeah you know maybe you are in this place that you don't want to be in or maybe you are in this place in the the profession that's really inconvenient, but it's, that's also really exciting. You know, it's like, we just tend to not fix systems until they completely cannot be fixed until they're
完全崩溃，你知道，而且，我们正处于那种状态。我的意思是，我认为这是一个时代，我们过去20年能够忽略的好主意，我们可能无法再忽略10年了。哦，是的。这就是心理学和这些心理学住院医师令人兴奋的事情之一，我有几个，就像，我厌倦了药物路线。我们必须找到不同的东西，对吧？我说，该死，是的，我们必须。就像，是的，药物不能解决一切
completely broken, you know, and, and we're sort of getting there. I mean, I think that this is a time where the good ideas that we've been able to ignore for the past 20 years, we probably can't ignore for another 10. Oh, yeah. And that's one of the exciting things with psych and these psych residents is I have a couple of them like, I just, I'm tired of like the medication route. We got to find something different, right? I'm like, hell yeah, we do. Like, yeah, medication can't solve everything
在这些病人中的一些。而且它就像，它过去专注于那种，这是精神病学唯一能做的事情。而你正在得到这些想要退出的年轻住院医师。这就是我失去的人，他们有能力以另一种方式理解治愈，因为你拿走了除了药丸之外的每一个工具。所以现在每一个工具，每一个，你知道，如果你是一个锤子，一切看起来都像钉子，你失去了欧文·亚隆（Irvin Yalom）那些能够进行谈话治疗的人的所有机构智慧，因为你把医疗保健变成了服务，而那种服务意味着每个人都在看着心理学，就像你们做什么？我们是程序
in some of these patients. And it's just like, it used to be focused on that type of, this is the only thing psychiatry can do. And you're getting these young residents that want to exit. And that's what I'm lost people who had capacity to understand healing in another way because you took away every single tool other than pills. So now every tool, every you know, if you're a hammer, everything looks like a nail and you lost all the institutional wisdom of the irvin yalums of the people who could do talk therapy because you turned health care into a service and that service meant everyone's looking at psych being like what do you do we're procedure
导向的医疗保健，现在这里没有程序，只是谈话，就像，是的，就像我们希望你接生婴儿，而且不要治愈它，因为那会很昂贵，但请永远治疗癌症，就像，是的，你知道，就像那件事使这些医疗保健部门非常有利可图，而且让任何人怀疑你为什么要进入心理学，而心理学在任何地方都处于长期资金不足的状态，是的，但对我来说更邪恶的事情是，它采取了这些服务，并使它们持续5到15分钟，哦，是的，你对我一无所知，现在你让我服用影响我大脑的药物。嗯，那是治疗师工作45分钟的目的。但随后工作45分钟的治疗师不是它的一部分。
oriented health care now there's no procedure here it's just talking like yeah like we want you to deliver babies and don't cure it because that that would be expensive but just treat cancer forever please like yeah you know like that that thing made these sectors of health care very profitable and it made anyone wonder why you would go into psych and psych just kind of be chronically underfunded everywhere yeah but the the more nefarious thing about it to me is that it took these services and made them 5 to 15 minutes long oh yeah you don't know anything about me and now you're putting me on drugs that affect my brain. Well, that's what the therapists working 45 minutes are for. But then the therapists working 45 minutes aren't part of it.
你知道，你没有配对。即使是那些像，嗯，研究走向那个方向之类的。不，它没有。研究总是说，我的意思是，撇开我们为了让抗抑郁药看起来比实际更有效而编造的所有事情，它总是说这些东西在大多数情况下只是有效的，而在所有情况下
You know, you're not pairing. Even the people who are like, well, research went that way or something. No, it didn't. Research always said, I mean, taking aside all of the things that we made up to make antidepressants look more effective than they were like it always said that these things were in most cases only effective and in all cases
几乎所有情况下，当你把抗抑郁药与治疗结合起来时更有效，是的，所以它不是基于证据的，不要告诉我那个，因为你并没有说走出治疗室，然后去和精神科医生谈话，那不是你做的，你知道，是的，而且并没有说走出治疗室，然后去和精神科医生谈话。那不是你做的，你知道吗？现在我们已经失去了这个医学领域中所有知道如何与某人谈话一小时的人的机构知识。所以这很可怕，但如果你是一名MD并且想要炸毁那个世界，也很令人兴奋。是的。而且那是，而且那是，我正在做的事情。我进行的每一次谈话都在说，就像，如果你确实想要那种改变，你必须，你必须接受，一，感受
almost all cases more effective when you combined antidepressants with therapy yeah so it wasn't evidence-based don't tell me that because you weren't saying go out of the therapy office and then talk to the psychiatrist that isn't what you did you know yeah and weren't saying go out of the therapy office and then talk to the psychiatrist. That isn't what you did, you know? And now we've lost all of the institutional knowledge of the people who knew how to talk to somebody for an hour in this whole field of medicine. So that's scary, but also exciting if you're an MD and it wants to blow that world up. Yeah. And that's and that's something that I'm doing. Every conversation that I had is kind of saying, like, if you do want that change, you got to be you got to be okay with one feeling
那种同情疲劳和倦怠的症状，嗯，因为你会撞到砖墙，对吧？你现在想要改变，但你不能，你是一名住院医师，然后在住院医师之外，你正在寻找那份好工作来弄清楚并做，你成为系统中的另一个齿轮，你知道吗？还是你打算，你知道，在里面放一个螺丝刀，尝试做一些不同的事情，嗯，这有点像填补那些，但它，它就像他们对一些，嗯，每个人通常只是对一些砖墙感到满意，嗯，而且你知道，那些砖墙在某个时间点倒塌了，这只是当，嗯，而且是如何保持那种韧性，
symptoms of that type of compassion fatigue and burnout um because you're going to run into brick walls with that right you want to change right now but is you can't you're a resident and then outside of residency you're looking for that good job to like figure out and do you become another cog you know in the system or are you going to you know put a screwdriver in it and try to do something different um and it's kind of filling those out but it's it's like them being okay with some of the um and everyone in general just being okay with some brick walls um and you know those brick walls come down at some point in time and it's just when uh and it's how to maintain that resilience,
通过它。这有点像那种宁静祷文。你如何接受你无法改变的事情，改变你能改变的事情，而且，只是让某人帮助你经历那个，你知道，有时它更像是一个维恩图，
uh, through it. It's kind of the serenity prayer of that. How do you accept the things that you can't change and change the things you can and, and just having somebody help you go through that, you know, sometimes it's more of a Venn diagram,
就像你说的，一些砖墙随着时间倒塌了，但我们，我们确实，我认为我们可以，我们倾向于用头撞击我们还没有接受它们存在的墙。是的。当你进行治疗时，有人说，是的，你不能那样做，我们确实，我认为我们可以，我们倾向于用头撞击我们还没有接受它们存在的墙。是的。
like you're saying, some of those brick walls come down with time, but we, we do, I think we can, we tend to beat our head against walls that we haven't accepted are there yet. Yeah. And when you get in therapy and somebody says, yes, you can't do that, we do, I think we can, we tend to beat our head against walls that we haven't accepted are there yet. Yeah.
当你进行治疗时，有人说，是的，你不能那样做，你知道，但你可以在哪里重新引导那种能量？你可以在哪里重新引导时间？那时事情就会改变。是的。
And when you get in therapy and somebody says, yes, you can't do that, you know, but where can you redirect that energy? Where can you redirect times? That's when things change. Yeah.
我的意思是，那，那有点像它是什么。它是，你知道，我们必须把能量重新引导到正确的事情上。我经常谈论生产力，是，你知道，
I mean, that's, that's kind of what it is. It's, you know, and we have to redirect the energy to the right things. I talk about productivity a lot is, you know,
每个人都认为，就像生产力是同时做所有事情。但它实际上只是关于在正确的时间做正确的事情。完全正确。是的。是的。而且不，请继续。我只是在说。而且这有点像对倦怠的关注，就像每个人都认为。是的。所以每个人都认为我们必须做所有事情，这就是我们能实现的。但它实际上是关于选择正确的事情并对此感到满意。但这需要一个像你这样有深度和某种存在主义倾向的人才能理解。我的意思是，我认为为什么很多只是高性能的专业人士，他们是，你知道，
everybody thinks like being productive is doing everything all at once. But it's really just about doing the right time, right things at the right time. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. And no, go ahead, please. I was just saying that. And that's kind of the focus on burnout is like everybody thinks. Yeah. So everybody thinks we have to do everything and this is what we can achieve. But it's really about kind of picking the right thing and being OK with that. But it takes somebody with your depth and kind of existential bent to be able to understand that. I mean, I think why a lot of just higher performance professionals that are, you know,
聪明，并且已经对这些困难的事情进行了反思，它们是悖论。没有简单的解决方案。你知道，他们害怕他们最终会得到，你知道，某种回避的、仅认知的、你知道，认知行为支持咨询师。那只是像，嗯，也许那是有原因的。嗯，你知道，你知道，也许你应该为你正在用头撞击的墙感到感激，你知道，而不是只是像，是的，那是一件坏事，伙计。那很糟糕。而且它不会改变。也许它会在五年内改变。但我们现在能做什么？你知道，我们能做什么？不幸的是，大多数治疗并没有从那里开始。在我的
bright and have already kind of ruminated on these things that are hard and they are paradoxes. There's not an easy solution. You know, they're afraid that they're going to end up with, you know, sort of avoidant, cognitive only, you know, cognitive behavioral supportive counselor. That's just like, well, maybe that was there for a reason. Well, you know, do you know, maybe you should just be grateful for the wall that you're beating your head against, you know, instead of just like, yeah, that's a bad thing, man. That's bad. And it's not going to change. And maybe it will change in five years. But what can we do now? You know, what can we do? Unfortunately, the most therapy just doesn't start there. In my
经验中，是人们试图劝你放弃你的情绪，这看起来很奇怪，你知道，但不，他们会让你标记它，但你知道，然后你必须远离它，是的，那里有太多东西，是的，嗯，是的，我迷路了，所以如果我，抱歉，哦，是的，抱歉，你很好，如果你有，所以如果你有，你知道，10，5，10，只是医生进来的概念，你知道，有人在这些系统之一中进来，你知道，这不是急性创伤，不是像他们正在发生一件事，但它是压力创伤，而且一直有太多的能量被激活，我的意思是，你在哪里，你在哪里开始，我的意思是，你经历的前，你知道，五个事情是什么，筛选前进，只是，你知道，实际上作为一个
experience, it's people kind of trying to talk you out of your emotion which seems weird you know but no they'll let you label it but you know then you gotta zing away from it yeah there's so much there yeah um yeah i'm lost so if i'm sorry oh yeah sorry you're good if you've got so if you've got you know 10 5 10 just concepts that a doctor comes in you know somebody in one of these systems comes in you know it's not an acute trauma it's not like they're having one thing happen but it is strain trauma and that there's just too much energy activated all the time i mean where do you where do you start i mean what are the first you know five things you go through screen forward to just you know practically as a
治疗师，正在治疗那些东西，是的，嗯，基本上它在多大程度上影响了你的功能，对吧？而且为了维持你现在正在做的事情，你牺牲了什么，嗯，并试图重新引导，你知道，基本上它作为一个人对你有什么影响，它对你周围的人有什么影响，嗯，它是否创造了，你知道，共病诊断，你抑郁吗，你，你的焦虑水平是多少，或者你知道，评价它，对吧，但你对自己有多协调，对吧，你有没有注意到它让你感觉如何，就像什么是倦怠，你必须注意到并走过那对你来说感觉是什么，而且这对每个人都不同，让我们看看，嗯，是的，它确实不同，对于
therapist that's treating that stuff yeah uh basically how much is it has it affected kind of like your functioning right um and what have you kind of sacrificed uh in order to maintain what you are doing now um and trying to redirect you know basically how has it affected you as a person and how has it affected people around you um does it create you know comorbid diagnosis is are you depressed are you how much is your anxiety level or you know rate it right um but how much are you attuned to yourself right um have you have you noticed how it makes you feel like what is burnout you have to kind of notice and kind of walk through what that feels like for you and it's different for everyone um let's see uh yeah it is different for
很多人，但实际上它是，你继续下去的可能性有多大？就像你必须问那个问题。就像如果你在这个空间里，对吧，你想继续在这个空间里吗？你想继续这种感觉吗？你想让这种情况继续下去吗？目的。你为什么要做这个？你还记得吗，或者你考虑过那个吗？
a lot of people but really it's it is of the, how likely are you to continue on? Like you have to ask that question. Like if you're in this space, right, do you want to continue in this space? Do you want to keep feeling like this? Do you want this to keep going? Purpose. Why are you doing this? Do you remember or have you thought about that?
是的。然后有点重新定义你的激情。你的激情可能从医学院到现在已经改变了，对吧？让我们帮忙。让我们帮忙弄清楚那个。你的激情仍然是人，就像你不会仅仅因为你想做手术而成为医生。就像你，你仍然在帮助某人，或者，或者只是大联盟，对吧？
Yeah. And then kind of redefine your passion. Your passion may have changed from med school to now, right? Let's help. Let's help figure that out. Your passion is still people like you don't become a doctor just because you want to do surgery. Like you're, you're still helping somebody or, or just big leagues, right?
你，你有一家公司，你对成长某事充满激情，对吧？你的激情，你的，你的激情在那里。然后当你开始失去它时，它不一定，你知道，而且这也是你必须谈论的事情。你是在失去那种激情，还是它只是在你前进的过程中被重新定义了？你对那种重新定义感到满意吗？所以，你知道，有很多，我的意思是，是的，有很多事情你在期间查看和筛选，但它绝对是你如何，它击中你的地方，就像身体上，对吧？
You, you, you have a company, you're passionate about something to grow something, right? Your passion, your Your passion was there. And then when you start losing it, it's not necessarily, you know, and that's something you have to talk about too. Are you losing that type of passion or is it just being redefined as you go? And are you okay with that redefinition? And so, you know, there's a lot of, I mean, yeah, there's a lot of things that you look at and screen for during this, but it's definitely how you are, where it hits you, like physically, right?
然后是你的思维过程。是的，里面有很多东西。而且就像我说的，它是因人而异的。每次都会不同，因为那种倦怠看起来不同，那种同情疲劳对每个人看起来都不同，而且只是谈论你在哪里，或者有没有一个时间你没有这种感觉，对吧，以及你现在在哪里，什么不同了，嗯，诸如此类的事情，是的，而且只是知道我们被允许改变，就像已经很长时间了，我的意思是，医生也是，我认为那是那些职业之一，有些人只是被告知他们会做那个，他们会进入它
And then your thought processes. Yeah, there's so much in it. And like I said, it's per person. It's going to be different every time because that burnout looks different different in that you know that compassion fatigue looks different to everyone and it's just talking about where were you or is there a time when you didn't feel this way right and where you are now and what was different um and things like that yeah and just knowing we're allowed to change like it's been a long time i mean and doctors too i think that's one of those professions where some people are just told that they're going to do that that they're going to go into it
而且有点放下别人的目标，或者，你知道，家庭遗产去说我想做什么，是很多人开始揭开的一个大事情，我现在，我真的很兴奋，当你，嗯，开始做大脑定位（Brainspotting）时，我们可以复习SLT，因为你谈论的很多东西，就像当某人你让他们注意到一种情绪时，这太有趣了，而且有这种巨大的躯体反应，就像每次我感觉到这个，我的背部做这个，我的心脏做这个，我的胃做那个，而且只是用瞳孔测量法，就像用眼球运动，你可以在10分钟内弹出那个，然后它就消失了，然后他们开始感觉到所有那些感觉，并回到下一次会议，我的意思是，就像那是一件如此整洁的事情，就像为什么，嗯，我不知道，很多在
and kind of putting down somebody else's goals or you know the family legacy to say what do i want to do is like a big thing that a lot of people start to uncover i'm now i'm really excited for when you uh start to do brain spotting and we can go over slt because a lot of what you're talking about it's like it's so much fun when somebody you get them to notice an emotion and there is this huge somatic reaction of like every time i feel this my back does this my heart does this my stomach does that and just with the pupilometry like with the eye movement that you can just pop that in 10 minutes and then it it's gone and then they start feeling all those feelings and and come back the next session i mean like that's such a neat thing it's like one of the reasons why um i don't know a lot of the stuff at
Tabry的东西就像工作得非常快，因为你只是跳跃启动，而且它就像你在治疗中最终会到达那里，但很多你的基于大脑的医学东西只是让改变发生得如此之快，它真的，是的，我绝对认为大脑定位和你的SLT将成为帮助人们的一个巨大因素，嗯，特别是，是的，达到那部分，并只是有点解锁大脑的那部分，只是为了通过那个，因为那是另一件事，就像倦怠可能是过去创伤的症状，真的，是的，我的意思是，那种旧关系，但甚至不知道，你知道，是的，那里有东西，而且它有点像弄清楚它，就像我说的，如果你没有命名它，就像如果你没有坐
tabry just like works really quickly because you're just jump starting and it's like you would have gotten there eventually in therapy but a lot of your brain-based medicine stuff just make change happen so fast it's really yeah i definitely think brain spotting and and your slt is going to be a huge like factor in helping people uh specifically yeah reaching that part and just kind of unlocking that part of the brain just to get through that because that's another thing too like burnout could be a symptom of past trauma really yeah i mean and that old relationship but not even knowing you know yeah there's something there and it's kind of like figuring it out and like I said if you haven't named it like if you have not sat
下来并命名它，那么你将永远无法克服那种事情，它正在尝试回到那个根源，而且只是，而且真的做任何可能的事情来，有点真的把你带到你需要去的地方，而且那意味着回去或谈论创伤，谈论，你知道，通过它，通过它工作，处理它，嗯，但是的，大脑定位将会是，当你，当你接受培训时，它将会相当不错，或者当你，是的，那是下周，对每个人，你知道，哦，酷，我希望，是的，让我知道进展如何，如果你想坐下来玩一会儿，我们，嗯，我们总是喜欢做咨询，就像，嗯，玩弄技巧和不同的东西，嗯，因为我不知道，它，它真的很整洁，它改变了，它让我做我已经在做的一切更快，是的，而且用，你知道，非常少的
back and named it then you'll never be able to overcome that kind of thing it's trying to get back to that route and just and really do anything possible to kind of really get you to a place where you need to be and that and that means going back or talking about trauma talking about you know getting through it working through it processing it um but yeah brain spotting is going to be it's going to be pretty good when you when you have the training or wouldn't you yeah that's next week to each you know oh cool i hope yeah let me know how it goes and if you want to sit down and play with it for a minute we uh we always like do consultations and like uh play with like tips and different things um because i don't know it's it's really neat it changed it let me do everything that i was already doing faster yeah and with you know very little
某种，嗯，我不知道，它不是一个协议繁重的东西，它是一个相当自然的东西，是的，它，是的，它，深入研究并只是有点看看我们可以在哪里扩展它会很好，真的，我的意思是，你不会经常看到它，嗯，你注意到像很多医生或很多那种高性能个性的人，就像有某种慢性的但高度功能的，你知道，他们已经学会了如何管理它，ADHD或其他某种，你知道，复杂的创伤，你知道，有很多障碍，有点来自混乱的童年，在那里，那里，要么有创伤，要么你只是有点没有得到足够的。你知道，我认为ADHD是那些事情之一，那里绝对有相关性。
kind of uh i don't know it's not a protocol heavy thing it's it's a pretty natural thing yeah it's yeah it's uh it'll be good to dive into and just kind of see where we can expand it really i mean you don't see it often um do you notice that like a lot of physicians or a lot of those kind of high performance personalities like have just kind of a chronic but highly functional you know they've learned how to manage it in adhd or other kind of like complex trauma you know there's a lot of disorders that kind of come from a chaotic childhood where there, there was either trauma or you just kind of weren't getting enough. You know, I think ADHD is one of those things where there's definitely a correlation.
而且我记得医院，太多的医生，就像他们没有为此服用药物或任何东西，但它就像他们的整个板子会有便利贴，16个警报正在响起。而且是因为他们，他们只是找到了一种在环境上控制这个东西的方法，嗯，但我认为，你知道，我想如果你正在处理MD，你也会看到很多ADHD，哦，是的，那，我的意思是，那个，而且有这种，就像特发性的和发作性睡病，我正在处理，这似乎每个人这些天都在得到这些，而且它，嗯，我认为它与某种，就像过去的创伤有关，然后
And I remember the hospital, so many of the doctors, like they weren't medicated for it or anything, but it was like their whole board would have post-it notes and 16 alarms are going off. And it was because they, they had just figured out a way to environmentally control this thing um but i think you know i would imagine if you're dealing with mds that you're also seeing a lot of adhd oh yeah that i mean that and there's this kind of like idiopathic and narcolepsy that i'm dealing with too that it seems like everybody's getting these days and it's uh i think it's linked to kind of like past trauma and then
是的，而且他们没有处理它，对吧？所以是的，这是我所看到的范围，而且有，就像，是的，那里绝对有一个模式，所以，嗯，有什么我们没有达到的，或者你觉得是方法的一个重要部分，以及你想要如何，我不知道，那里有什么吗？是的，不，我在这里攻击一切，对吧？而且它不仅仅是，你知道，是的，不仅仅是倦怠和一些同情疲劳。我帮助很多焦虑和创伤。所以我不是，你知道，我喜欢这一切。我认为这一切在某个时间点是齐头并进的。
yeah and they're not dealing with it right so yeah it's a spectrum of what i do see and there is like yeah there's there's definitely a pattern there so well um is there anything that we don't get to or you feel like is is an important part of approach and how you want to, I don't know, anything there? Yeah, no, I'm here to attack everything, right? And it's not just, you know, yeah, not just burnout and some compassive fatigue. I help a lot with anxiety and trauma. So I'm not, you know, I like it all. I think it all goes hand in hand at some point in time.
所以那个，而且这是我充满激情的事情，并确保我们大家都对它有更多的认识，而且只是，而且我在这里提供帮助。所以。嗯，听起来不错。有什么，有什么事情，你知道，不仅仅是你的专业，你认为会是，就像，某种有趣的，有趣的话题，或者任何你想在未来做一集的事情。
And so that, and it's something I'm just passionate about and make sure that we all kind of get more aware of it and just, and I'm here to help. So. Well, sounds good. Is there any, anything that has to do, you know, not just with your specialty, you think would be like kind of a fun, fun topic or anything you want to do an episode on in the future.
而且接下来的几件事我很兴奋，因为爱丽丝（Alice）在水下，她要，她合作主持了一两次，然后她变得很忙。但当每个人都在网络中，每个人都在进行时，我想要更多只是某种圆桌会议，无论什么，不必，
And the next couple of things I'm excited that with, cause Alice got underwater, she was going to, she co-hosted like once or twice and then she got busy. But when everybody's in network and everybody's going, I'd like to have more of just kind of a round table, whatever, not have to,
得到一些，一些不同的主题，以及，以及桌子上的东西会很整洁，我们对它们都有不同的看法，是的，我听你的阴谋论，它们太有趣了，嗯，马修·林斯基（Matthew Rinsky）和他们，是的，而且，嗯，邪教，而且，那些太疯狂了，你从来没有想过，就像只是谈论那些类型事情的心理学，但它们很棒，那是我想要用播客和博客做的方向。就像我只是，我对，就像，感觉你可以做心理健康播客的两种方式，或者像，好吧，温柔的朋友，
it'd be neat to get some, some different topics and, and things on there on the table we all have different perspectives on yeah i listen to your conspiracy ones and they're so funny uh matthew rinsky and them yes and uh the cults and uh those are so wild you never think about like just talking about the psychology of those types of things but they're great that was kind of the direction i wanted to do with the podcast and the blog. Like I just, I had no interest in, in being like, it feels like the two ways that you can do like a podcast on mental health or to be like, all right, gentle friends,
如果能把一些不同的主题和内容摆到桌面上来讨论会很棒，我们每个人都有不同的视角。是的，我听过你们关于阴谋论的那几期，真的太有趣了，马修·林斯基他们那一期，还有关于邪教的那些，真是太疯狂了。你从来没想过可以单纯地从心理学角度去探讨这些事情，但它们真的很棒。那正是我想要通过播客和博客呈现的方向。我根本没兴趣，感觉做心理健康类播客通常只有两种方式，要么就是，好吧，温柔的朋友们，
remember to eat ginseng under the moon or like the other one is to just be like, all right, 10 ways that the government is making your gut inflamed by you, not whatever. Also, like I just got cancelled you know while i was recording i go i get a bunch of emails about that one guy i don't i don't know anything about him i mean it looks like the kind of thing where like half of it is kind of like yeah that seems like smart you know forward-thinking anti-establishment medicine that makes sense and then the other half is kind of like i don't know man does sunscreen really give you cancer i haven't seen those
记得在月光下吃人参，或者像另一个那样，只是说，好吧，政府有10种方法让你的肠道发炎，而你却不知道。另外，我刚被取消关注了，你知道吗？我在录音的时候收到了一堆关于那个人的邮件，我对他一无所知。我的意思是，这看起来像是那种一半看起来很聪明、有前瞻性、反建制的医学建议，很有道理，而另一半看起来就像是，我不知道伙计，防晒霜真的会让你得癌症吗？我没见过那些
numbers. That Huberman guy, do you know who I'm talking about? I don't know anything about him, but I just get emails where people tell me to listen to it and I don't have any time. It just came out that he had 10 wives or something. What was the scandal? I've not been that in depth, but I do
数据。那个Huberman，你知道我在说谁吗？我对他一无所知，但我总是收到邮件，人们让我去听他的节目，但我没时间。最近刚爆出他有10个妻子还是什么的。丑闻是什么？我没有深入了解，但我确实
know that I did see some something he got. I think he had a bunch of secret girlfriends or something and they all talk to each other. Sounds like a cult. I thought everybody that had a mental health podcast was allowed to do
知道我确实看到了一些关于他的东西。我想他有一堆秘密女友之类的，她们还互相交流。听起来像个邪教。我以为每个做心理健康播客的人都被允许做
that, but I guess it's good. I just have 10 cats. I'm happily married. Really boring in that regard i don't know how do you have time that's the thing that gets me is like i i've heard of like there are people in my family you know businesses or whatever and you have like stuff just comes up you're like i'm like doing stuff all day like i imagine that this is a time-consuming thing like how are you this duplicitous? I don't have time for lunch.
那种事，但我猜这很好。我只有10只猫。我婚姻幸福。在这方面真的很无聊，我不知道你是怎么有时间的，这才是让我困惑的地方。就像我听说我家里有人，你知道，做生意什么的，事情总是接踵而至，我整天都在忙，我想这应该是一件很耗时的事情，你怎么能这么两面派？我连吃午饭的时间都没有。
I'm a social worker. Exactly. Going on dates with 10 people? How do you do that? I've made that joke with my wife several times five years ago. She's just like, are you sure you're here? You're only're only for me i was like i don't have enough energy for you well i mean i i should probably figure out what andrew huberman actually did before i talk about oh yeah what if we're yeah but like i mean i think that was that he just had like a bunch of girlfriends or something but it was like i i really don't understand how uh yeah i've got
我是个社会工作者。没错。同时和10个人约会？你是怎么做到的？五年前我曾多次和妻子开过这个玩笑。她只是说，你确定你在这里吗？你只属于我。我说我没有足够的精力去应付别人。好吧，我的意思是，在谈论他之前，我可能应该先弄清楚Andrew Huberman到底做了什么。是的，如果我们要谈论的话，但我的意思是，我想那是因为他只是有一堆女朋友之类的，但我真的不明白他是怎么……是的，我有
two kids like i have i have a wife or we have a cat box to empty we have a you know fish to feed like i just how do you do that like there was a guy when i worked with um people that uh were treatment resistant like schizophrenia there was a guy that he would have a good relationship with you and then you know five or six weeks in he would go through every case manager because he would start to get paranoid and he would be like well you came and we brought the food and you gave it to me and that was very nice but i heard when you were going to your car that you like quickly looked over your shoulder and you said you know butthole and that was about me and and and i know that they are getting to you now and making you do this or whatever so i'd worked with him for a while and they were like
两个孩子，我有妻子，我们要清理猫砂，我们要喂鱼，就像我不知道你怎么做到的。我以前和一个治疗抗拒型精神分裂症的人一起工作时，有一个人，他会和你建立良好的关系，然后五六周后，他会经历每一个个案经理，因为他开始变得多疑，他会说，好吧，你来了，你带了食物，你给了我，这很好，但我听说你走向车子的时候，你快速地回头看了一眼，你说你知道，混蛋，那是针对我的，我知道他们现在正在影响你，让你做这些事，或者其他什么。所以我和他工作了一段时间，他们说
you know just be aware i was like the only one that worked with him for like more than a year but like we're like just be aware he's gonna like the only one that worked with him for like more than a year. But like, we're like, just be aware. He's going to start doing this thing. And I came in the door at some point and Violet had just been born and I looked terrible. And he was telling me about how he knew the CIA was like giving me orders or something. And it's like, dude, I have a newborn baby. Look at my eyes. Look at me.
你知道，要小心。我是唯一一个和他一起工作超过一年的人，但他们说，只要小心点，他会开始做那种事。有一次我走进门，Violet刚出生，我看起来糟透了。他正在告诉我他知道中情局在给我下命令之类的。就像，老兄，我有个刚出生的婴儿。看看我的眼睛。看看我。
I walked out of the house without shoes on today. I'm not wearing a belt. And he was like, oh, OK, yeah okay yeah you're right no it's like i don't have time to be running the world like he was like he like grounded me and i looked terrible enough that he became you grounded him to where he was he's like oh shit he's right this guy's off yeah the same he doesn't hire people that look like this yeah this guy looks awful this guy came off the street yeah well i don't know um yeah but i think like part of the thing with the podcast was like i wanted to be able to get like people who were smarter than me to talk about how there's inherent psychology and all these things like oh yeah and architecture and
我今天没穿鞋就走出了家门。我没系皮带。他就像，哦，好吧，是的，好吧，你是对的，不，我没时间去统治世界。他就像……他让我感到羞愧，我看起来糟透了，以至于他变得……你让他感到羞愧，他觉得，哦该死，他是对的，这家伙不对劲。是的，他不会雇佣看起来这样的人。是的，这家伙看起来糟透了，这家伙是从街上来的。好吧，我不知道，嗯，但我认为播客的一部分原因是我希望能够让比我聪明的人来谈论这些事情中内在的心理学，比如建筑和
then it isn't just kind of like we go to therapy to do the psychology but then we pretend it's not real when we're doing the rest of our life i think is a lot of the problem that I'm trying to with therapy point out we shouldn't do like, you know, that that psychology is a part of us and kind of learning to hold that is is a. I don't know, I would like to change the way that we think about it you know oh yeah we i think we do need to change i mean i think that's a that's a given right now is we do need to kind of change the way that we think about a lot of things um and bring bring young back you know oh yeah yeah yeah some of it some of the young and stuff um i mean the the problem with that kind of psychology is because i like i like you a lot but it's like what you're doing is saying that we're only half empirical that the other half is subjective and that you can sort of have best practices for dealing with that but you can't quite have rules and measurable objectives because you can't see it you know there is this
然后这不仅仅是我们去接受心理治疗，但在做其他生活琐事时却假装它不存在。我认为这是我试图通过治疗指出的很多问题，我们不应该这样做。你知道，心理学是我们的一部分，学会去接纳它是一个……我不知道，我想改变我们对它的看法。你知道，哦是的，我认为我们确实需要改变，我的意思是，我认为这是一个既定事实，我们确实需要改变我们对很多事情的看法，并把荣格带回来，你知道，哦是的，一些荣格的东西。我的意思是，那种心理学的问题在于，因为我很喜欢你，但你所做的是说我们只有一半是经验主义的，另一半是主观的，你可以有处理这些问题的最佳实践，但你不能完全有规则和可衡量的目标，因为你看不到它，你知道，有这种
objective thing that um yeah like you have to just at some point make a jump that somebody can know that another person is having an emotion and feel what they're doing and read them and they don't need 50 screeners for anxiety maybe we should just hire people that sort of know if someone else has anxiety that they're talking to you know in the field but when you have something that's half empirical and half subjective it's inherently ripe for kind of abuse by nefarious parties because yeah you can't prove it you know and um a lot of the things that were i mean i think that's the rudolph steiner thing is like a lot of the stuff that we're the most insecure about as a society is some of the most important
客观的东西，嗯，是的，你必须在某个时刻做出跳跃，让一个人知道另一个人正在经历某种情绪，感受到他们在做什么，读懂他们，他们不需要50个焦虑筛查表。也许我们应该只雇佣那些在领域内能看出别人是否有焦虑的人。但是当你拥有半经验半主观的东西时，它本质上就容易被邪恶方利用，因为你无法证明它，你知道，而且很多事情，我的意思是，我认为那是鲁道夫·斯坦纳的东西，作为社会，我们最不安全感的一些东西，恰恰是最重要的
but it's not measurable and it's not visible and because we can't represent it objectively we tend to neglect it kind of you know yeah i mean that's a that's a good point especially like spirituality right you know and that being part of a person you know how do you you know someone comes in and they're saying i'm just wrestling with i'm wrestling with this i'm wrestling with being a being here and a being elsewhere it's like how do you how do you how do you tell somebody oh you know your spirits looks pretty good you know yeah yeah yeah well yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah. And that'd be a fun one. I'd like to do another episode with Alice where we just kind of like round table, talk about spirituality from different perspectives. Cause I mean, the thing is like,
但它不可衡量，也不可见，因为我们无法客观地表现它，我们往往会忽视它，你知道。是的，我的意思是，这是一个很好的观点，尤其是灵性，对吧？你知道，那是人的一部分，你知道你怎么……有人进来，他们说我正在挣扎，我正在挣扎，我正在挣扎于作为一个在这里的存在和一个在别处存在的人。就像你怎么告诉别人，哦，你知道你的精神看起来不错，你知道。是的，是的，好吧，是的。好吧，是的。那会很有趣。我想和Alice再做一期节目，我们只是围坐在一起，从不同的角度谈论灵性。因为我的意思是，事情是这样的，
I would talk about spirituality a lot in therapy with people who are atheists and I'm just like, yeah, you know, like the purpose of your life and a greater energy when you feel your intuition and you know, but I hear so many therapists say like, like oh well you can't talk about that because um i don't know if they believe what i believe and it's like most people probably know people believe what i believe like i'm i'm i don't why why would you assume that you would need to you know like you don't need to try and tell the patient that their spirituality is bad or hit it with a newspaper that they need to convert to another religion but it's fine to just be like you know some people are going to very naturalistic in their language you know they're going to say like i feel the presence of jesus i feel held i feel good
我在治疗中经常和无神论者谈论灵性，我只是说，是的，你知道，比如你生命的意义，当你感受到直觉时，有一种更伟大的能量，你知道，但我听到很多治疗师说，哦，好吧，你不能谈论那个，因为……我不知道他们是否相信我所相信的，这就像大多数人可能知道别人相信我所相信的，我不知道为什么你会假设你需要，你知道，你不需要试图告诉病人他们的灵性是坏的，或者用报纸打它，让他们皈依另一种宗教，但只是说，你知道，有些人会用非常自然主义的语言，你知道，他们会说，我感受到了耶稣的存在，我感到被拥抱，我感觉很好
that's a good thing you know other people are going to say i went and i grounded and i talked to the earth and it whatever i don't need to jump in and say whoa whoa what do you mean how much of that is empirical let's let's go ahead and list all of your assumptions there like why can't i talk about that with somebody even if you know like i am agreeing with them that that's their experience and that's like a good thing and these parts may not be the right you know maybe trying to solve like your tax return to spirituality is not great you can wave the amethyst at the irs but i don't think they're going to go away so maybe let's put spirituality in this sector of your life that single man yeah yeah i i mean i maybe i'm missing a gene but i just hear that over and over where people are like well you don't know what they believe religiously or they don't know so i can't talk about it it's like why would you
那是一件好事，你知道。其他人会说，我去接地了，我和大地交谈了，不管怎样，我不需要跳出来说，哇，哇，你是什么意思？其中有多少是经验性的？让我们继续列出你所有的假设。为什么我不能和别人谈论那个，即使你知道，我同意他们的观点，那是他们的经历，那是一件好事。这些部分可能不是正确的，你知道，也许试图解决你的纳税申报单到灵性是不太好的，你可以对着国税局挥舞紫水晶，但我认为他们不会走开，所以也许让我们把灵性放在你生活的这个部分。单身汉，是的，是的，我的意思是，也许我缺少一个基因，但我一遍又一遍地听到人们说，好吧，你不知道他们在宗教上相信什么，或者他们不知道，所以我不能谈论它。就像为什么你会
not talk about it i don't get it yeah that's still part of the person that we can that we're talking to right now like yeah um yeah and and i think we we can understand each other's like humanity but we don't have to understand every person's exactly you know unique perspective like we to a certain extent we can't you know i don't know well um i really appreciate your uh time I don't run too much over you'll have to shut me up on these like I need I need like a you know you know yeah or maybe I just we should have a cough button but it's y'all's so you can just hit it you know my mic or not but yeah this is a this is great'll uh we'll get it out and then if you have any other topics or anything that'd be fun let's try and do one of these more more free definitely we'll have to we'll see how um yeah especially after brain spotting uh just see kind of how that
不谈论它？我不明白。是的，那仍然是我们现在正在交谈的人的一部分，对吧？是的，嗯，是的，我认为我们可以理解彼此的人性，但我们不必理解每个人的每一个独特的视角，就像我们在一定程度上做不到的那样，你知道，我不知道。好吧，嗯，我真的很感谢你的时间。我没有超时太多，你得阻止我，我需要一个，你知道，是的，或者也许我只是……我们应该有一个咳嗽按钮，但这是你们的，所以你可以直接按它，你知道，我的麦克风或者不，但是的，这太棒了，我们会把它发布出来，然后如果你有任何其他话题或任何事情，那会很有趣。让我们尝试做一期更自由的，肯定会的，我们会看看，嗯，是的，特别是在脑点疗法之后，看看它是如何
we can incorporate that and talk about that so well thanks man we will get together with you and talk again soon somebody call for a doctor I think I'm sick you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you Well, that sounds great man. We will follow up with you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们可以结合起来谈论它。好吧，谢谢伙计，我们会和你聚在一起，很快再谈。有人叫医生吗？我想我病了。好吧，那听起来很棒，伙计。我们会很快和你跟进。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。